.
MISTER CHAIRMAN EVERY RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS OF
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
FORTY ONE WHICH IS THE.
.
SUNSET EXTENSION WITH RESPECT.
TO THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR.
THIS SIMPLY EXTENDS THE.
BOARD FOR ADDITIONAL FOR YEARS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
XENON WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SHE NOT ONLY MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO.
ASK ANY QUESTIONS SING NON.
BUT MISTER CHAIR THE SUIT ENJOYS
A SPORTS BAR RECOMMENDATION
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR VOTE FOR THE SIMPLE
EXTENSION.
WE'LL TAKE UP ONE WHERE QUORUM.
FILE ITEM TO A. B. THIRTY ONE
FORTY TO THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
MISTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR ME TO PRESENT ON ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO.
FIRST OFF TO NAY DOLLARS THE
PREFIX I THINK THEY AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN ANALYSIS AYE WITHIN
MINUTES THE BILL. EXTENDS A
SUNSET DATE FOR THE ACUPUNCTURE
BOARD BY TWO YEARS AS NOTED IN
OUR SUNSET BACKGROUND PAPER.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT A TWO YEAR
SUNSET EXTENSION IS BRIGHAM SOME
BUT WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE BOARD TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THESE DIFFERENT
OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IN
RESPECT WE ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
UP TO HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SE NON WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SHE NINE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO SPEAK.
CENA.
THIS CHAIR THIS ENJOYS OF
SUPPORT SUPPORT AS AMENDED AND
WHICH LIKE CLUBS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND RESPECT THEY ASK FOR A
VOTE WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL
TAKE THAT UP WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM AS YOU MENTIONED.
FILE ITEM THREE A. B. THIRTY
ONE FORTY THREE. RELATED TO TAX
PREPARERS MUST CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THIS IS THAT THE
SENSE THAT VEHICLE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION COUNCIL
OR SEE TECH THE BILL SIMPLY
EXTENDS THE SUNSET. DATE BY
NATIONAL FOR YEARS AND CONTAINS
NO OTHER PROVISIONS AT THIS TIME
WITH RESPECT TO ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YES MA'AM.
YOU CAN COME UP AND IF YOU LIKE.
HELLO I'M SOLANO RACE DIRECTOR
OF STATE LOCAL POLICY FOR
PROSPERITY NOW. WE ARE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
EXPANDING FINANCIAL STABILITY
WEALTH AND PROSPERITY FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
PART OF THIS WORK ENTAILS
INSURING THAT OUR TAX SYSTEM IS
FAIR FOR LOW WEALTHY FAMILIES
INTO THIS AND WE CAN VIA TAX
FAIR OPPORTUNITY NETWORK.
I AM THAT REPRESENTS DATA
THOUSANDS OF DEDICATED TO ME.
OPERATIONS SPECIALIST ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I'M AND EACH YEAR THEY PREPARE
THOUSANDS OF RETURNS AND CORRECT
ERRORS MADE BY PAID TAX
PREPARERS. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN I
REPORT FROM THAT YALE AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL REVEALED THAT.
I SIXTY PERCENT ERROR RATE FOR
PAID TAX. IN SO GIVEN THE
CHANGES IN THE STATE TAX CODE
AND THE INCREASING COMPLEXITY OF
THE FEDERAL CODE. HOLDING PAID
PAID TAX REPAIRS ACCOUNTABLE CAN
HELP REDUCE ERRORS AND ENSURE
FILERS.
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME FILERS.
MAKING SURE THAT THEY GET THE
FULL BENEFIT OF THE CODE. WE
HAVE THE FOLLOWING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION AND BUT WE DO
SUPPORT WITH THESE AMENDMENTS.
ENSURING TRANSPARENCY SO MAKING
SURE THAT OF P. TAX REPAIRS ARE
DISCLOSING THEIR THERE'S FEES
AND FOR SERVICES NOT JUST REFUND
ANTICIPATION LOANS AND TAX.
INSTITUTING A STANDARDIZED EXAM
WE KNOW THAT THIS COULD AYE
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF PAY TAX
REPAIRS BUT. WHEN WE TALK TO
FOLKS IN OTHER STATES LIKE
MARYLAND THE BOARD OF INDIVIDUAL
TAX PREPARERS FOUND THAT THERE
WAS AN INITIAL DEBT. BUT MANY
BECAME ENROLLED AGENTS AFTER
THAT AND SO LASTLY ANOTHER
AMENDMENT IS TO PUBLICIZE
COMPLAINTS.
MAKE CREATING A PUBLIC DATABASE
OF COMPLAINTS WOULD HELP
CONSUMERS COMPARE PREPARES.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP THE HAVE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD MAKE
DETERMINATIONS ABOUT POTENTIAL
SUSPENSIONS.
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A FEW OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT ALL HOLDEN
AND THERE AND OVERALL PROSPERITY
NOW SUPPORTS THREE ONE FOUR
THREE WITH THESE AMENDMENTS.
LIKE FOR TESTIMONY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OUTWARD BEAUTY DON'T KNOW WITH
UNITED WITH CALIFORNIA AND WERE
IN A SUPPORT IMPLEMENTED.
POSITION.
WE WE SEE THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STRIKE IN THIS
PART OF THE CODE WE HAVE A
CHANCE ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS TO.
MAKE IT BETTER.
AND TO.
REALLY LOOK AT TO PAY TAX
REPAIRS WHO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MOST PERSONAL.
INFORMATION AND FINANCIAL
INFORMATION OF THE CONSUMER AND
WE THINK IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD IN THE.
AMENDMENTS THAT.
SOLANO REFERRED TO WHEN CLUED
IN TRANSPARENCY OF FEES AND
OTHER THINGS ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND SOME MORE OVERSIGHT BY BOTH
CTEC AND THE FTP.
THANK YOU DISH WITNESSES AND
SCORE.
SELECT HERITAGE CELESTE HERITAGE
ADMINISTRATOR CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS EDUCATION CONSUL IN
SUPPORT OF THE AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SHE NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHES TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE SIDE OF.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIR THIS IN
GEORGIA SUPPORTS FOR
RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU LIKE
CLUBS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TRAVEL. THANKS
WE'LL TAKE THAT UP TO ME
ESTABLISH QUORUM FILE ITEM FOR
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR.
AS CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS
RICE YOUR THIS IS THE LAST OF
OUR SUNSET ITEMS TO THIS IS A
WITH RESPECT TO OUR
PROFESSIONAL.
FIDUCIARY IS BUREAU AND EXTENDS
ITS OPERATION FOR FOUR
ADDITIONAL YEARS I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF IN PARTICULAR
DANIEL FOR WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE.
OF BECAUSE A KNOW THAT IT TAKES
A GREAT AMOUNT OF WORK AND
PREPARATION AND WITH RESPECT TO
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK MACHINE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A JURY MEMBERS JERRY DOES MEN OF
HAVE THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA OF THE
ASSOCIATION WAS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE LEGISLATION THAT
ESTABLISH THE ACT. I THINK ABOUT
THREE QUARTERS OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED LICENSEES CURRENTLY
BELONG TO P. FACT WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY WORDED THAT
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET. ON THE
ACT FOR FOUR MORE YEARS WOULD
LIKE TO TOUCH UPON BRIEFLY THE
FIVE POLICY ISSUES OF THAT ARE
SET FORTH IN THE ANALYSIS FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OUR
SUPPORT FOR THESE. ONE IS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE ACT BE
EXTENDED IN ORDER TO INCLUDE OF
LICENSURE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
PERSONAL REPRESENTATIVES
APPOINTED BY THE COURT FOR
DECEDENTS THE STATE'S.
THE SECOND IS TO ADD CLARITY FOR
THE ENROLLED AGENT PROVISIONS IN
THE ACT THE THIRD IS TO PROVIDE
PROVISIONS OF THAT SPEECH SET
FORTH THE CRITERIA FOR THE
BILLING OF CLIENTS OF FOR THEIR
OF RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS.
CONDUCTED BY THE.
FIDUCIARY.
THE FOURTH IS TO PROVIDE A
PATHWAY FOR LICENSURE FOR FIVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE THAT WAS IN
THE ACTED IT REGIONALLY WE THINK
SHOULD BE A RE ESTABLISHED AND
THEN FIFTH TO ADD.
SPECIFICITY TO THE ANNUAL
REPORT FILED BY FISHERIES WITH
THE BUREAU TO SPECIFY IF THEY
RESIGNED A CASE A DUE TO A. IN A
DIRECT RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS
HAVE BEEN FILED OF EACH OF THOSE
WHO ARE CANDIDATES FOR INCLUSION
AND WE WOULD SUPPORT IF CRAFT IT
THE RIGHT WAY THAT THEY BE ADDED
TO THE ACT AS IT MOVES FORWARD
DOWN FOR ANOTHER FOUR YEARS OKAY
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. FOR.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NOT MEMBERS OF
THE SIDE OF.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIRPERSON
GEORGIA SUPPORTS FOR
RECOMMENDATION WOULD LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE WILL
TAKE TO SIGN HIM UP WON'T BECOME
A QUORUM SEE THE NEXT OFF AUTHOR
MISTER COOPER FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
ILLEGAL CANNABIS TASK FORCE.
IN JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU OF CABS
CONTROL BEGIN ISSUING CANNABIS
LICENSES.
WHERE THE FORMER CHEMIST
OPERATORS HOSTED LICENSES IN THE
LARGEST CANNABIS MARKET CAN OUR
COUNTRY?
IT'S CALIFORNIA LEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET BEGINS TO ESTABLISH ITS
FOOTING IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
STEPS BE TAKEN TO WEED OUT
ILLEGITIMATE CUSTOMERS AND
THAT'S NO PUN INTENDED.
THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET CALIFORNIA'S
ALSO HOME TO THE LARGEST ILLEGAL
MARKET.
KOREA HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY
FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION OF
CALIFORNIA'S SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN CANADA CELLS ARE
GENERATED BY UNLICENSED
UNREGULATED GROWERS
DISTRIBUTORS.
DISPENSARIES.
TO REMOTE ILLEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET PREVENT ILLEGAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTION AND AVOID ILLEGAL
DIVERSION OF CANNABIS TO OTHER
STATES. CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE
AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO ATTACK
I CANNABIS BLACK MARKET.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY STEPS IS A
TASK FORCE
TO BRING TOGETHER STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
AND INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS TO
DEVELOP STRATEGIES
TO COMBAT CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERGROUND CANNABIS ECONOMY.
I SAID THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENCED DUST IF WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE
WHO COOPER ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. SEEN NO
DISH NO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TINA WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS SUMMER COOPER
DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL.
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND TAKE A
VOTE.
WHEN WE.
HAVE A QUORUM AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AND
IF YOU THINK YOU.
OKAY WHEN I MOVE ON.
LET'S SEE WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
AUTHOR HERE AND THAT IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
SENATE RODRIGUEZ PLEASE PRESENT
IN EVERY READ. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA SAW OVER TWO THOUSAND
APPARENT OVERDOSE DEATHS AND
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND MERGE ROOM
VISITS FOR A PRIORI OVERDOSES.
ARMY THIS.
STATE OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
THERE WERE TWENTY FOUR MILLION
OVER PRESCRIPTION THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WERE
REQUIRE HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS TO ADOPT A SAY
PRESCRIBING PROTOCOL WITH THE
GOAL OF REDUCING UNNECESSARY
HOPE YOUR PRESCRIPTIONS.
PARTICLES PARTICLES WHAT DRESS
RECOMMENDED DOSE AND DURATION
FOR PATIENTS EXPERIENCE TO PAIN.
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENTS REFERRAL
GUIDELINES BETWEEN PRIMARY AND
SPECIALTY CARE. AND PATIENT
EDUCATION ON THE RISK OF
OPIOIDS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FOR YOU TO WATCH DATA FROM THE
CHURCH DATABASE AND TRACK THE
REDUCTIONS OFF YOUR
PRESCRIPTIONS.
I TAUGHT TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
SE PRESCRIBE PARTICLES WILL NOT
APPLY FOR PATIENT THE CHRONIC
PAIN COUNTS OR NEED OF HOSPICE.
PUBLIC OF CARE FOR AND OF LIFE
CARE.
MEMBERS THIS BILL CONTINUES TO
BE A WORK IN PROGRESS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING.
AND CONTINUE DISCUSSION WITH THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO STRENGTHEN
THIS LEGISLATION AND ACHIEVE A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION AND UP
YOUR PRESCRIBING.
WITH ME TODAY IS LOUIS BROWN I'M
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA.
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN TO HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS PROFESSIONALS
HOW WE ARE THE STATE'S LARGEST
CERTIFICATION ORGANIZATION FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE COUNSELORS. AND.
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF THE
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
TO INDIVIDUAL SUFFERING FROM
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
DISEASES.
IT IS NO SECRET THAT OUR NATION
AND OUR STATE IS FACING A
SIGNIFICANT A OPIOID CRISIS AND.
WE'RE THANKFUL TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FOR THIS BILL TO
ADDRESS JUST ONE ELEMENT OF THE
PROBLEM THAT WE SEE WHICH IS. A
PRESCRIPTION.
ABUSE.
AND.
WE THINK THAT BY PROVIDING SOME
REASONABLE SAFEGUARDS
I AT THE FRONT END OF THE
PROCESS WILL DEFINITELY HELP.
WITH THE ABILITY TO START TO
CURB AT THIS CRISIS THAT WERE
SEEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN ITS
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
HE DO VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE JUST NAME IT
AFFILIATION FOR THE RECORD IF
YOU DO STILL DO SO. AT MISTER
MEMBERS DAVID GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA'S POSITION GROUPS WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS OR TAKE ON A PER
ELEVENTH AND CONTINUE WORK ON
THIS BUT WE APPRECIATE ANY
DIRECTION THANK YOU.
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS RAN MARK
NUMBER HAVE THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
OUT OF THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM THANK YOU.
CHRIS THREE CALIFORNIA IS WILL
THERE BE ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WE LIKE
TO CONTINUE COMPETITION WITH THE
AUTHOR AROUND CHRONIC PAIN.
JACOB AND YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMITTEE
TO PAY FOR HEALTH AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT OF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGLE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
KENNY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME VICE
CHAIR BROKE.
THANK YOU MISTER ABOUT MISTER
RODRIGUEZ THANKS SO MUCH RAIN TO
SUPPORT THIS IS A.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CRISIS FACES
ARE ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND.
I KNOW.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THEY'RE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WHERE
THIRTY PRESCRIPTIONS OBSOLETE
AND I THINK ON THE RIGHT TRACK
HERE BUT. NOT IN YOUR OWN WORDS
I THINK IT YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS I'LL
GET SEEN APPROACH NUMBER VOTE
FOR TODAY TO KEEP MOVING BECAUSE
I THINK.
A THING ON THE RIGHT TRACK WE
JUST GOT TO GET THE DETAILS
WORKED OUT SO THANKS SO MUCH FOR
BEING THIS FOUR. PICKET VERSION.
AND I'M SORRY DID WAS THERE
ADDITIONAL WOODS IS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COME
EXPEDITIOUSLY WOULD COME UP TO
THE MIKE AND WHEREVER YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
MAKE IT ALRIGHT ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
STILL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON
THIS LANGUAGE.
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
WORK THAT THE AUTHOR HAS PUT
INTO THIS BILL. AND AND THE
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH CMA ON AS WE MOVE FORWARD
ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS TO MEN
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
AMERICAN BECAUSE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN THE SAME POSITION
CMA WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF'S TIME AND CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THEM THANK YOU.
I'M MICROBES HERE I'M WE HAVE
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS A NINE INCH
OPPOSITION I'M JUST A LITTLE
LATE I'M I I JUST REALLY WANTED
TO.
COMMENT ON THE EVE SQUISHED I'M
NOT SUCCESS SPORTS ALL THE
BILL'S AUTHOR.
ARE MOVING TOWARDS STATE.
AND SAFE PRESCRIBER PROTOCOLS
INCLUDING AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT.
AND THAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGED.
THIS COMMITTEE AND AND AND THE
OTHER COMMITTEES CONSIDER THAT
THE ROLE OF URINE TESTING IN AND
OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS ON THAT
THAN THE CDC GUIDELINES IN THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
GUIDELINES. BOTH THAT BOTH
RECOMMEND AND URINE TESTING AS A
AS A BASELINE SO THAT PHYSICIANS
ARE AWARE OF DRUGS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN A PATIENTS THAT
SYSTEM AND AND.
AND AND PERIODIC TESTING TO
HELP WITH THAT HEARINGS AND ON
AND TO PREVENT A DIVERSION.
MRS.
INSTANCES AND I EDUCATING
PHYSICIANS AND EDUCATE THE
PATIENTS ON ON A FEW SUBJECTS
THINKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM KEY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ DO YOU WISH TO CLUBS.
YES I JUST WANNA LET JOB
CONTINUE WORK WITH OTHER MEMBERS
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE WE GET
AS BILL THE RIGHT WAY. WE KEEP
CLOSED OFF THE STREET TOWARD AND
OF BEING ONE TO OVER PRESCRIBE
WITHOUT.
BUT FOR ASPIRIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY RODRIGUEZ WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AYE NEXT THAT WILL
GO ON TO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SELF.
JUST A REMINDER WHAT A PROVIDE
UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR IT WHEN
HE SAYS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR OPENNESS IS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
A SIMILAR THOMAS WELCOME PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
GIVE SPOKEN TO ALMOST EVERY.
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE ALREADY
ABOUT VALLEY FEVER.
AND.
YOU KNOW I CAN TELL YOU.
VALLEY FEVER CURRENTLY HAS NO
VACCINE NO CURE.
WE KNOW THAT ACCORDING TO THE
CDC EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CASES GO UNREPORTED
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
WE KNOW THAT ABOUT SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
VALLEY FEVER DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE IT.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO WHICH
TRYING TO GET AT THE
MISDIAGNOSIS WE SEE THAT. IT'S
ESTIMATED ANYWHERE BETWEEN SIXTY
AND EIGHTY PERCENT.
OF THE FOLKS THAT.
ULTIMATELY ARE DIAGNOSED OR
MISDIAGNOSED
INITIALLY AND WHAT THAT MEANS
INITIALLY IS THAT THEY'RE GIVEN
ANTIBIOTICS THAT DON'T TREAT
VALLEY.
SO WITH THAT LET ME JUST TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THE
BILL WOULD DUE TO HELP CORRECT
THIS MISDIAGNOSIS.
.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH ON LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS TO MAKE AVAILABLE
PROTOCOLS AND GUIDELINES BASED
ON THE MOST.
RECENT SCIENTIFIC AND MEDICAL
EDUCATION ON VALLEY FEVER TO
EDUCATE PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ON THE
CAUSES OF THE DISEASE
TRANSMISSION AND STATE NURSES
SURVEILLANCE AND TREATMENT.
WHILE EXISTING REGULATIONS
ALREADY REQUIRE PHYSICIANS TO
REPORT CASES OF ALLAH THEORISTS
AND LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES PRIMARY CARE
CLINICS.
AND GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS
TO DEVELOP ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A
WRITTEN POLICY. AND PROCEDURE
REGARDING.
REQUIRED REPORTING TO THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS ON THE CASE
OR A SUSPECTED CASE OF VALLEY
FEVER ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THAT PEOPLE INFECTED BY
VALLEY FEVER FACE. IS THAT THE
DISEASE'S FREQUENTLY
MISDIAGNOSED
AND WITH THAT I DO HAVE ONE OF
MY. JOINT AUTHORS WHO WILL.
SHARE HIS STORY ABOUT OUT HERE.
THANK YOU A SIMILAR MEMBERS
HOUSE.
SO COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND.
CHAIR I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS SOMEONE THAT WAS
MISDIAGNOSED.
AND WAS GIVEN MEDICATION THAT
REALLY DIDN'T HELP MY SITUATION
BECAUSE I HAD VALLEY FEVER.
AND I IT WASN'T UNTIL A NURSE.
CAME IN AND ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
ME. AND I ASK IF I'D BEEN GIVEN
MEDICATION I SAID YES AND.
I TOLD WHAT THE.
BUT WHAT THE MEDICATION WAS AND
SHE WAS LIKE THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HELP YOU HAVE VALLEY FEVER NOW I
DON'T KNOW HOW SHE KNEW THAT.
BUT FOR SOME REASON SHE WAS ABLE
TO SEE IT AND.
SEE THE.
.
THE SEE WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
AND IMMEDIATELY THE DIRECTION
WAS CHANGED
THE CORRECTION WAS MADE AND THAT
I WAS ABLE TO IMPROVE SO I AM A
LIVING TESTIMONY. OF EXACTLY WHY
WE NEED THIS BILL TODAY.
CLAIMS SUBMISSION ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES SUPPORT IT WON'T KILEY
DELGADO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO
BE HERE IN SUPPORT WE THINK IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT
WILL HELP EDUCATE THE COMMUNITY
AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ABOUT
THIS VERY SERIOUS ILLNESS.
AND ONE OF THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ISSUE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NON MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE WISHING TO SPEAK
MISTER FALL.
AS AS SOMEONE WHO'S OUT OF THE
CERTAINLY REPRESENTING SCHERING
AREA THAT MISTER SALAS AND I.
HAVE THAT DIDN'T IN TERMS OF BY
PEOPLE BEING SO PREVALENT I
THINK THE AUTHOR FLORA FOR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE THINK THAT MUCH.
BIGGEST PHONE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK.
SEEING NONE.
THIS IS ALSO DON'T CLOSE.
JUST LIKE YOU HEARD FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE MISTER GRAYSON YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT THIS HAS CASE
ISN'T THE ONLY CASE THAT'S
OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
BEING MISDIAGNOSED AND THIS IS A
STEP THAT WILL HELP. CORRECT.
.
THAT.
THAT INEQUITY SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK MASALA US.
WERE SUBCOMMITTEE AT CURRENT
TIMEZONE BE STABBED QUORUM WILL
TAKE THAT UP FOR A VOTE. ALRIGHT
THANK YOU YOU HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ITEM FILE ITEM SIX.
AB EIGHTEEN OH TWO.
PRONTO CONSENT SO SYMBOL.
PASS ON THAT ONE ALRIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOUR SOCKS.
BECAUSE.
WHERE TAKE A BRIEF? BREAK WHILE
WE WAIT FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
TO APPEAR PRESENT
SEE THE PRESENCE OF MISTER CHAU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT FILE
ITEM NINETEEN AB THREE ZERO SIX
SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I A. B. THIRTY SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD PROHIBIT THE
OPERATOR OF AN INTERNET WEBSITE.
OR ONLINE SERVICE APPLICATION OR
MOBILE APPLICATION FROM
MARKETING CANNABIS PRODUCTS OR
SERVICES TO MINORS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN SP FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR STEINBERG
ESTABLISH THE PRIVACY RIGHTS FOR
CALIFORNIA MINERS IN A DIGITAL
WORLD STATUTE. WHICH PROHIBITS
THE OPERATORS OF INTERNET
WEBSITES ONLINE SERVICES ONLINE
APPLICATIONS AND MOBILE
APPLICATIONS THERE ARE DIRECTOR
AT.
TO MINORS FROM MARKETING
CERTAIN TYPES OF PRODUCTS OR
SERVICES SELL TO MINORS FROM
MARKETING I'M.
HOW TO PURCHASE A SUCH AS
ALCOHOL AND TOBACCO THE LAW ALSO
PROHIBITS ALL WEBSITES AND
SERVICES FROM MARKETING SUCH
PRODUCTS TO A MINOR? IF THE
OPERATOR HAS ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE
THAT A MINOR IS USING THAT
WEBSITE OR ONLINE SERVICE.
THE LAW PROHIBITED DRUCK UP
PARAPHERNALIA FROM BEING
ADVERTISED TO MINORS HOWEVER DID
NOT SPECIFICALLY PROHIBIT THE
ADVERTISING OF CANADA'S. BECAUSE
AT THE TIME RECREATIONAL USE OF
CANNABIS WAS NOT LEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL AB TO I THIRTY SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD REMEDY THIS
SITUATION BY ADDING TOWN OF IS
TO THE LIST OF ITEMS THAT ARE
PROHIBITED FROM BEING
ADVERTISED.
ON CHILDREN'S WEBSITE.
NOW ADDING CANNABIS TO THIS LIST
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT THESE
ONLINE OPERATORS SO ARE
PROHIBITED FROM MARKETING
CANADA'S PRODUCTS.
TO A PERSON UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN IF THE OPERATOR HAS
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE UNDER EACH
OTHER INDIVIDUALS USING OF THE
SERVICE ARE ONLINE.
WELL THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
CONSIDER ON AN ONLINE OPERATE
OPERATOR TO BE IN COMPLIANCE SO
WITH THIS LAW. IF THE OPERATOR
TAKES REASONABLE ACTIONS IN GOOD
FAITH ARE DESIGNED TO AVOID
MARKETING OF THE PRODUCT YOU ARE
THOSE UNDER EIGTEEN. ARE AND
FINALLY THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
THE OPERATOR WHAT THIRD PARTY ON
HIS BEHALF FROM KNOWINGLY USING
A DISCLOSING OR COMPILING
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF SOMEONE
UNDER EIGHTEEN. WHEN THIS
INFORMATION WOULD INDEED BE
USEFUL MARKETING OUR OR
ADVERTISING OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS
ARE A TWO MINOR A WE GOT I
RESPECTFULLY HOUSE OF WE ARE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CHALLENGES IN
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS NO MORE WHETHER
SOME OF THE LOCAL NONPROFIT
YOUTH FORWARD AND ME IN MY
ORGANIZATION ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF AYE CMG CLEAVE OUT OF
SAN JOSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WE WOULD SUGGEST.
THAT THE AUTHOR LEAST LOOK AT
ONE THING WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE MEAN MEDICALLY ALLOWED
TO HAVE CANNABIS BETWEEN THE
AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
THERE MIGHT BE SOME
CONSIDERATION FOR A.
ALLOWING THOSE TO BE.
MARKETED TO THANK YOU THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NOT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO SPEAK.
CENA WAS SHALL WE JOIN CLUBS
IDEA I SWEAR I WILL TAKE YOU.
THIS ENJOYS A SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES AND WILL TAKE THIS UP ONLY
SALVAGE CORPS THAT IMAGE THANK
YOU.
SHE ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD LIKE TO
PERCENT.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX
.
MORE IN THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ENGAGING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
WHICH I BELIEVE STRENGTH IN THE
DRAFTING OF THE LANGUAGE.
NEARLY TWO DOZEN COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS WERE IMPACTED
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRE SEASON
PUTTING THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS
CARE RISK.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX TAKES
THE RECENT EXPERIENCES OF
CLINICS PHARMACIES AND HEALTH
PROVIDERS INTO ACCOUNT.
THE PROPOSES CHANGES THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR CAN CONTINUITY OF
CARE IN THE FACE OF NATURAL
DISASTERS.
THIS BILL SETS OUT AN
ACCELERATED PERMITTING PROCESS
FOR TEMPORARY PHARMACY LICENSES
DURING A PROCLAIM STATE OF
EMERGENCY. WHICH IS THE CENTRAL
WHEN A HEALTH CENTER HAS BEEN
DESTROYED OR CANNOT OPERATE THE
PHARMACY TO DISPENSE MEDICATION
TO PATIENTS.
AUTHORIZING THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY TWO ISSUED TEMPORARY
PHARMACY LICENSES TO CLINICS AND
MOBILE PHARMACIES. WILL PROVIDE
PATIENTS IN DISTRESS.
ACCESS TO MEDICAID MEDICATIONS
WITHOUT DISRUPTION.
IT IS IN EVERYONE'S BEST
INTEREST TO TEMPORARILY INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY DURING THESE TRYING
TIMES TO PROVIDE FOR OUR
PATIENTS NEEDS.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE WITH
ME TODAY IN SUPPORT MILLION FARE
FROM THE DIRECTOR OF COMPLIANCE
ASSURANCES SANTA ROSA COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER AND. MAY CONSUMERS
FROM CALIFORNIA HEALTH. OUT
ADVOCATES.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KNOWING PHARAOH I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF COMPLIANCE INSURANCE AT SANTA
ROSA COMMUNITY HEALTH.
A NONPROFIT FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER PROVIDING
OUTPATIENT MEDICAL DENTAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. AT ELEVEN
CAMPUSES FOR OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS THROUGHOUT SANTA ROSA.
THE MAJORITY OF THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WE SERVE ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY.
ONE THIRD OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
CHILDREN.
MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILY WE CARE FOR ALREADY
STRUGGLED WITH HIGH HOUSING
COSTS AND HOMELESSNESS BEFORE
THE FIRES.
ON OCTOBER NINTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SANTA ROSA COMMUNITY
HEALTH'S LARGEST HEALTH CENTER A
VISTA CAMPUS WAS DESTROYED. DUE
TO EXTENSIVE FIRE SMOKE HEAT AND
WATER DAMAGE IN THE FIRE STORM
THAT HIT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OF NOTE THE VISTA CAMPUS WAS
HOME TO ONE OF JUST TWO
PHARMACIES COLOCATED AT SANTA
ROSA COMMUNITY HEALTH SITES.
IN A FEW SHORT HOURS TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND OTHER PATIENTS LOST
THEIR MEDICAL HOME. WHERE THEY
HAD RECEIVED COMPREHENSIVE
PRIMARY CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES?
AND HOUR ORGANIZATION WAS DOWN
TO JUST ONE PHARMACY DEDICATED
TO SERVING ALL OF SANTA ROSA
COMMUNITY HEALTH PATIENTS.
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
COLOCATED PHARMACY SERVICES ARE
ORGANIZATIONS SET SUSTAINABILITY
AND OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTH AND
WELL BEING WAS. AND STILL IS AT
RISK.
WHILE THE FIRES WERE STILL
RAGING WHILE OUR PHONE LINES
WERE DOWN AND OUR IT SERVERS
WERE DESTROYED. WHILE WE WERE
STILL TRIAGE IN OUR DAMAGES AND
MANAGING TEMPORARY CLOSURES AT
VARIOUS SITES.
DUE TO SMOKE AND CHANGING FIRE
PATTERNS WE NEVER STOP PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE OF PATIENTS NEEDED.
I PRIORITIES REMAIN TO SEE ALL
OF OUR PATIENTS WHO NEED CARE
AND SERVE ALL OF THEIR NOON
NEEDS. INCLUDING ACCESS TO
PHARMACEUTICALS AND MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT.
TO PROVIDE MEDICAL MEANINGFUL
WORK FOR OUR EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPLY SPACE FOR A NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND FAMILY PRACTICE
RESIDENTS TO CONTINUE.
THEIR TRAINING.
OVER A THREE MONTH PERIOD IN
LATE TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TO
DOESN'T HEALTH CENTER
CORPORATIONS SERVING A TEN
COUNTY REGION AND ROUGHLY EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS WERE
IMPACTED BY FIRES.
WHEN THE HEALTH CENTER OR A
COLOCATED PHARMACY HAS BEEN
DESTROYED DAMAGED OR CLOSED. THE
PHARMACY SERVICES INCLUDING THE
DISPENSING OF MEDICATION IS
IMPACTED TO.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED TO PRESERVE
PHARMACY ACCESS DURING AND
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
DECLARED EMERGENCY.
LAST OCTOBER WHERE AND WHEN IT
WAS SAFE TO OPERATE* CENTER
STAFF RUSHED TO PROVIDE PRIMARY
CARE ANYWAY THEY COULD. AND WE
IMMEDIATELY TRY TO RESTORE THE
LEVEL OF PHARMACEUTICAL ACCESS A
PATIENT'S RELIED ON.
BUT AS I SIT HERE TODAY THE
LEVEL OF PHARMACY ACCESS IS
STILL NOT WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE.
AND THE IMPROVEMENTS WE HAVE
NEED HAVE TAKEN FAR TOO LONG.
WHILE EXISTING LAW ALREADY HAS
SIGNIFICANT ALLOWANCES FOR
EMERGENCY PRESCRIPTIONS AND
PHARMACY ACTIVITIES DURING
EMERGENCIES.
THERE WAS NOT CLEAR ENOUGH
GUIDANCE IN THE LAW AS IT
RELATES TO CLINIC PERMITS FOR
PHARMACIES AND COLOCATED
PHARMACIES.
AS A RESULT AFTER WE IDENTIFY
THE HEALTH CENTER SITE WHERE WE
WANTED TO PROVIDE POST DISASTER
PATIENT SERVICES. THERE WERE
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS FOR OUR
CLINIC DISPENSARY TO BECOME
OPERATIONAL.
SIMILARLY AS WE RUSHED TO OPEN A
NEW SITE PLANNEDPRIOR TO THE
FIRE STORMS BUT NOW NEEDED MORE
URGENTLY. WE AGAIN FOUND THE
CURRENT LICENSING PROCESS TO BE
LIMITING.
AND WHILE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY RESPONDED TO OUR
URGENT NEEDS AS BEST THEY COULD.
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT WE COULD DO
BETTER TO SUPPORT DECISIVE QUICK
RESPONSES BY CREATING A CLEAR
POLICY PATH. THAT IS NOW BUILT
INTO AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX.
WE MUST LEARN FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO MAKE SURE HEALTH
CENTERS ARE BETTER PREPARED TO
CONTINUE DELIVERING CARE. DURING
AND AFTER DECLARED EMERGENCY
AND THIS BILL AIMS TO PROVIDE
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY ADDITIONAL
TOOLS NECESSARY TO STREAMLINE
THE PERMITTING PROCESS FOR
CLINIC PHARMACIES.
AND LICENSING FOR COLOCATED
PHARMACIES DURING DECLARED STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY ON AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
SAY THANK IF I COULD JUST
INTERRUPT YOU FOR SECOND.
THESE QUORUMS ARE HARD TO CATCH
SO I AM GOING TO ESTABLISH IT
WHILE WE HAVE ONE. CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. LOW. BROW HERE
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
JILL. CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON. GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
TING.
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND%
DISC DOES ENJOY A SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES SO I WITNESSES I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF.
ABSOLUTELY MISTER CHAIRMAN STEVE
JOHNSON ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU POTENTIAL WITNESSES
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN THE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA OF THINK
THE AUTHOR. WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT SUSIE SHIP WITH
REDWOOD COMMUNITY HEALTH
COALITION WHERE CO SPONSORS ON
THE BILL WOULD SEE PCA AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHELLE EVANS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH THE HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ROSANNA CARAVAGGIO
HERE BEHALF ABREGO HEALTH A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
SHOW WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
SEEING NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THE SIDE OF.
SEEING NONE.
WHICH ARE CLOSED YES I WOULD
NONE OF US CAN EVER BE
COMPLETELY PREPARED FOR THE
DEVASTATION. AND OTHER TESTS ON
A TEST OF PEACE THAT PROVIDES A
TO THIS A PAID IT CHALLENGES
THAT COME WITH NATURAL
DISASTERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX
PROPOSES CHANGES WILL IMPROVE
THE ABILITY OF HEALTH PROVIDERS
TO DELIVER TIMELY ACCESS TO
SERVICES AFTER THE DISASTER
OCCURS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THERE WAS A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN EGGMAN AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED HER
PREPARATIONS LOW. BRO HIGH BROW
AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
SOME CALL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH MUCH.
SEE ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO HERE.
HE'D LIKE TO PERCENT YOU HAVE
TWO ITEMS YOU HAVE.
YEAH FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR THAT'S ON
CONSENT.
AND YOUR SECOND ITEM IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
IT'LL BE A SIMPLE ONE A TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THINK.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT YEAH SOME
BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHT BILL WHICH WILL SIMPLY
CHANGE THE NAME OF THE STATE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY OPTOMETRY TO
THE CALIFORNIA. BOARD OF A TAMI
TREE THIS TECHNICAL CLEAN THE
BILL WILL MAKE THIS THAT STATUTE
AND BOARD MATERIALS CONSISTENT
WHEN REFERRING TO THE STATE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EGO THANK YOU WITNESSES AND
SPARK.
CARE QUARTERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO SHOW WHAT MRS IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS A COMMITTEE
WISHING SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EYEBALLS THANK YOU THERE'S A
MOTION BY MISTER GIBSON A SECOND
BY MISTER GRAY AYE. GRAYSON AND.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED HER
PREPARATIONS LOW.
BRO AYE BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MULLIN TING.
TING AYE.
THAT'S ALL CALL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
IT WAS VERY MOTION BY MISTER
GRACE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SECOND BY THE VICE CHAIR.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND CONSENT IS FILE ITEM SIX AB
EIGHTEEN OR TO SALAS AND FILE
ITEM A AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
RUBIO.
MOTION ON BOTH BILLS IS D.
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW.
PRO BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
IRWIN IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
THANK YOU NEXT ITEM UP IS.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIX
THREE BY MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THIS BILL AIMS TO CURTAIL
PRESCRIPTION DRUG OVER PAYMENTS
BEING REMITTED TO PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGERS CONSUMERS
ASSUME THAT THE VARIOUS
DISCOUNTS NEGOTIATED BETWEEN
DRUG. COMPANIES INSURANCE AND
PBM IS PROVIDE THE LOS
PRESCRIPTION COSTS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN THE COPY BENEFIT FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IS HIGHER
THAN THE RETAIL PRICE.
SO THIS FIX IT THIS BILL FIXES
THAT IT ENJOYS THE SUPPORT
SUPPORT. AND THE.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY.
LISTS HOMES CEO AND COFOUNDER
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION.
ALONG WITH DINA MENDELSSOHN
SENIOR ATTORNEY AT CONSUMERS
UNION.
GOOD MORNING CARILLO HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
LIZ HELMS.
I'M PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION CAN TODAY WE ARE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
THREE.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OUR VIEWS REGARDING PBM
PRACTICE OF THE PROBLEM.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA
AND.
AND CO AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JIM WOOD IN AUTUMN BURKE FOR
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
THE FOUR SEASONS THE COALITION
OF MORE THAN THIRTY LEAVING
STATEWIDE CONSUMER HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SOME PROVIDER
GROUPS TO PROMOTE THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK OF
POLICYMAKERS. INDUSTRY LEADERS
PROVIDERS AND CONSUMERS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
PAINS TO CURTAIL PRESCRIPTION
DRUG OVERPAYMENT ALSO KNOWN AS
FAR BACK.
WHEN COMMERCIALLY INSURED
PATIENTS COPAYMENTS EXCEED THE
TOTAL COST OF THE DRUG TO THEIR
INSURANCE OUR PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGER.
THE GENERAL PUBLIC IS ONLY NOW
BEGINNING TO LEARN ABOUT THIS
TYPE OF ANTI CONSUMER PRACTICE.
WE BELIEVE TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
THREE HAS THE SOLUTION TO HELP
CONSUMERS.
ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
WOULD LIMIT THE AMOUNT HEALTH
CARRIER PBM MAY REQUIRE A
BENEFICIARY TO PAY AT THE POINT
OF SALE. FOR COVERED
PRESCRIPTION TO THE LOWEST
AVAILABLE COST WHETHER IS IT
APPLICABLE CARSHARING AMOUNT FOR
THE RETAIL PRICE.
ENSURING CONSUMERS ARE NOT
OVERPAYING FOR THEIR
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS.
THEY WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE RETAIL
PRICE INSTEAD OF JUST THE CO PAY
TO APPLY TOWARDS THEIR
DEDUCTIBLE IN OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUM. IF THE BENEFICIARY OPS
TO PAY THE CASH PRICE.
AND IN RECENT STUDY DONE BY U.
S. C. SHAPER CENTER FOR HEALTH
POLICY AND ECONOMICS IT SIGN IT
AND CITED BY ME THIRTEEN
PUBLICATION FROM KAISER HEALTH
NEWS. PATIENT OVER PAY FOR
PRESCRIPTION TWENTY THREE
PERCENT OF THE TIMES.
THIS IS NOT INSIGNIFICANT SHARON
OVERALL DRUG STANDING IN OUT OF
POCKET COSTS.
AND IN FACT ONE PBM SHOWED
REVENUE OF A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN BILLION AND A PROFIT OF
OVER FIVE BILLION WHILE TAKING
ITTLE OR NO RISK.
WHEN THE REST OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN BEARS ALL THE RISK THIS IS
QUITE A PHENOMENON.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE WILL
HELP TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS THROUGH BETTER ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE MEDICATIONS THAT
THEY DESPERATELY NEED. IT WILL
PUT AN END TO THE CLAWBACK AND
UNETHICAL BUSINESS PRACTICES.
CONSUMERS SHOULD ALWAYS.
POCKET ANY OUT THERE WILL
SAVINGS ON THEIR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS WE STRONGLY URGE.
YOUR VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION IN THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING THE
CHRONIC CARE COALITION TO
EXPRESS OUR VIEWS TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND US THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED IT DOES ENJOY
SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
ENCOURAGE THE WITNESSES TO KEEP
THE COMIC SHORT. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND UP IN SUPPORT.
DINA MENDELSSOHN CONSUMER UNION
THE ADVOCACY DIVISION OF
CONSUMER PORTS WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL
THINK IF.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
AND THE BLUE CROSS AND EXPRESS
GROUPS ON SPORTS.
MISTER CHAIRS MEMBERS TO MADDEN
RIBS IN THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MIXING IN TOWN BEHALF THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I DAVID GONZALEZ OF THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MRS JOHNSON AGAIN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TIM SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL EXAM ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
STEVEN SCHULTZ WITH ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU DISH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEN NON WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO SPEAK ON THE
SIDE OF.
SEEING NONE MRS AARON WOULD LIKE
CLUBS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION
BY MISTER GIBSON AND A SECOND BY
MISTER CHEN CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOST MISTER PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. BROW. BROUGH
AYE ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG.
PHONE AYE GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
SOME CALL LUCKY TO OPEN
TRADITION.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS HERE ONE
WE ASK COMMITTEE MEMBERS LED
BILLS HERE MISTER HOLDEN IF
YOU'RE READY PERCENT.
MISTER HOLDEN WILL BE PRESENTING
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY FOUR.
IN THIS ENJOYS.
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES.
BUT THEY CAN ALSO VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES.
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THEIR
AMENDMENTS.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY FOUR
REQUIRES THAT AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ANY NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED COMMERCIAL PLACE.
A PUBLIC AMUSEMENT HASTUR
INCLUDED AMBULATORY STALL THAT
MEETS THE STANDARDS SET FORTH IN
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS CODE.
AN AMBULATORY ACCESSIBLE TOILET
COMPARTMENT ALSO KNOWN AS
AMATORY STALL HAS EVERYTHING
THAT IT EIGHTY A WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE STALL INCLUDES BUT
WITHIN A STANDARD SIZE STALL.
THE AMATORY STALL WILL BE IN
ADDITION TO THE ADA WHEELCHAIR
ACCESSIBLE STALL.
FALSE CONTINUE TO BE A RISK
FACTOR FOR OLDER MEN ADULTS IN
THEIR DAY TO DAY LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU IS HOLDEN THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
I NOW BLOCK I AM MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND I AM VERY THANKFUL.
TO SOMEONE MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
TAKING THIS MATTER OUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO READ A SHORT
LETTER. FROM DOCTOR JOHN NORRIS.
AB TWO NINE NINE FOUR. GRABBED
ARES WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
I ONLY BLOCK OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE AND A FELLOW
MEMBER OF THE TO BROWN SUNSET
ROTARY CLUB. THIS SUBJECT OF
GRAB BARS WAYS RECENT INTERESTS
TO MAYBE BECAUSE OF THE PAST TWO
YEARS I HAD DIE LATERAL KNEE
REPLACEMENT SURGERIES WITH A
FOLLOW UP SECOND PROCEDURE. ON
THE RIGHT ME AND I WAS I STILL
DOING ALMOST DAILY
REHABILITATION THERAPY DURING
THAT TIME. I HAVE BECOME AWARE
OF THE DIFFICULTY AND
LIMITATIONS IMPOSED ON PEOPLE
WITH THESE IMPAIRMENTS I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF MY
IMPRESSIONS WITH YOU. TO ADD TO
THE OTHERS YOU ARE GATHERING TO
SUPPORT YOUR FINAL RESULTS IN
THIS AREA GREATLY NEEDED
ATTENTION. TRAVELING UP AND DOWN
ROUTE FIVE I FOUND
ESTABLISHMENTS WITH NARROW BACK.
ROOMS SPACIOUS BATHROOMS IN
BETWEEN BATHROOM SHORT LOAD
TOILETS AVERAGE HEIGHT. AND HIGH
TO IT TELOPEA ROSEN DISPENSERS
TOO FAR AWAY EARNS SOME CASES IN
THE WAY NOT ALL BATHROOMS ARE OF
THIS SIZE AND SHAPE TO MAKE A
MILLER ATION OF THE PROBLEM IS
SIMPLE. AS IT APPEARS ON THE
FIRST LOOK.
SUGGESTIONS TO CONSIDER GRAB OUR
SHOULD BE PRECISION SO AS TO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THE USER TO
APPLY LEVERAGE ENOUGH TO OPPOSE
GRAVITY WHETHER TRYING TO SIT
DOWN AND A CONTROLLER TO SANTA.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE ONLY ONE UPPER
LIMB IN USABLE CONDITION TO
ASSESS THEMSELVES THE WALL WITH
THE BAR MAY BE ON THE WRONG
SIDE.
YOU MAY NEED A BAR TO COME UP
FROM THE FLOOR VOTED PROJECT
FROM THE WHILE STANDING BEHIND
THAT TOO. AND EXTENDING TO ARTS
AND ANY OF THEM THERE NEEDS TO
BE SUPPORT GRABOWO AS I'M BOTH
SIDES OF THE TOILET. THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING THIS MATTER IT
HAS FLOWN UNDER THE RADAR FOR
TOO LONG AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR THE CONSIDERATION TODAY
THANK YOU TESTIMONY. DISHA
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES THEM.
ALAN BOARD TELL PALM AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE AND THE MARIN
COUNTY.
COMMISSION ON AGING.
I'M IN. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS OF LEGISLATION.
AND JUST WANT LEGISLATORS TO
REMEMBER ABOUT OUR AGING
DEMOGRAPHICS IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE.
INCREDIBLE AS YOU ALL KNOW SO
THIS.
IT BECOMES MORE AND MORE
IMPORTANT.
AS THE POPULATION AGES.
THANK YOU MICHELIN DECISIONS
FOR.
SEE NOT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
SEEK ON THE SECOND.
I JUST LIKE SERVICE HOLDEN THANK
YOU FOR THIS BILL AND ALSO TO
POINT OUT IT'S NOT JUST SENIORS
YOU SOMETIMES NEED HELP WITH.
WITH MOBILITY ISSUES AND GRAB
BARS.
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS WHO COULD
BENEFIT FROM HAVING A LITTLE
EXTRA HELP SOMETIMES.
SO MEMBERS WHICH
CITY.
XENA THERE WAS A MOTION BY.
.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON.
WAS TOLD WHICH WITH CLUBS.
WILL FIRST OF ALL I JUST THINK
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND I
WILL SAY THAT. WHEN OTHER
CALIFORNIA'S SENIOR LEGISLATORS
HAVE THEIR.
CAPITAL VISIT DAY THAT'S HOW WE
GOT THIS BILL THEY HAD A LIST OF
BILL IDEAS AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS
DUE. OF THE SENIORS WHO CAME TO
THE CAPITOL AND LISTED OUT THERE
ISSUES.
WE SORTED THROUGH IT FROM THIS
ONE I THOUGHT IT WAS WORTHY TO
CARRY FORWARD AND SO ON THEIR
BEHALF I RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK
INSTALLED.
CLERK IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. BROW BROKE
MY ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN
AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
FOR A LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OUT ON ITS
OWN.
YES SHE NO AUTHORS HERE PRESENT
LET'S NOT GO BACK THROUGH THE.
ITEMS.
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM ONE
WILL NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
CLUB.
OKAY WAS SPOKE WITH THIS ONE.
.
THIS MOTION A SECOND CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
ONE A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS LOW. BROKE I BROKE
MY ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
LET ITEMS ON CALL LATE FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO PAT ON.
NOT SEEING US ANOTHER AUTHOR
COMMAND MISTER CALDERON.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PERCENT FILE
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
EIGHT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANKS IN ONLINE NOTARY BELTS
GOOD BILL SCAN TO MAKE PEOPLE'S
LIVES EASIER RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS THIS
IS LIKE SEE I AM LIKE SEE HOWARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ESCROW
ASSOCIATION. AND THE NATIONAL
NOTARY ASSOCIATION. PAPER
STATUTES THAT ALLOW IN PERSON
NOTORIOUS NATION GO BACK TO
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THEY HAVE
WORKED WELL FOR THE MOST PART IN
CALIFORNIA BEEN AMENDED FROM
TIME TO TIME. BUT DO STILL
REQUIRE THAT A PERSON APPEAR IN
PERSON BEFORE A NOTARY PUBLIC
WHILE THIS IS GENERALLY SECURE
AND THE TRADITIONAL WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS WE RECOGNIZE THAT TIMES
HAVE CHANGED. WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE LIFE BETTER FOR PEOPLE WHO
DO NEED TO SIGN AWAY FROM A. IN
PERSON NOTARY SETTING AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ARE HERE TO. ANSWER
ANY%
QUESTIONS THANK YOU ISSUE IN
THIS IS A SPORT MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS CORDY JETS ON THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
WE BELIEVE THIS. NEW TECHNOLOGY
HAS MANY CONSUMER AND BUSINESS
BENEFITS.
ALSO I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEVIN
GOAL TO CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THINK THE OTHER FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
ENCOURAGE DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
FOR.
JOHN CALLED LARA BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
EMILY PAPPAS ON BEHALF NOTARIZED
ALSO IN SUPPORT TAKE YOU DO
SHOWING DECISIONS FOR.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO SPEAK ON THE
SIDE OF THIS VOTE.
I JUST GOT OUT CLARIFICATION LE
IF IF YOU DON'T MIND THAT I
COULD SEE WHERE THIS WILL BE
VERY USEFUL FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BUT THAT IS THE
INTENTION TO MAKE IT.
CIVIL.
TO CONSUMERS AS WELL.
YEAH BUT EASILY ACCESSIBLE.
GREAT TICKETS MY SEAL OF
APPROVAL.
THANK YOU INITIAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
YEAH.
OKAY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY
MISTER GIPSON OF THE SECOND BY
MISTER GRATION THIS DOES ENJOY
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES WAS CALLED
OVERLOOKED CLOSE RESPECT WESTERN
ABOUT. THANK IF CLERK KALRA.
BUSH IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
BROWN HI BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHEN.
CHIP.
COMING UP.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MULLIN. TING.
TING AYE.
SOME CALL IT KEEP IT OPEN FOR
TO.
THANK YOU FOR MEMBERS
DATA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING A NOTHER AUTHOR HERE
MISTER STONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PERCENT. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX OH EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PROVIDING ANOTHER PATH TO FOSTER
YOU.
WE KNOW THE STATISTICS.
THANK YOU THAT FOSTER YOUTH
REALLY STRUGGLE AND YET A LOT OF
WHAT TO BECOME SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WHAT THAT ALL THIS BILL DOES
IS GIVE THEM A DAD OPPORTUNITY.
BY PROVIDING A LITTLE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
SEEK THE.
STANDARDS OF BECOMING A SOCIAL
WORKER TO GO BACK OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO BRING WHAT THEY HAD
BROUGHT TO BEAR WHAT THEY HAD
GONE THROUGH INTO THE SOCIAL
WORK FIELD.
IT'S JUST PROVIDING A LITTLE BIT
OF A SET OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO THEM. WITH A LOAN AMOUNTS
HELPING THEM REPAY LOANS AND
FIND A A BETTER PATH FOR THOSE
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN IMPROVING
THEIR LOT IN LIFE. BECAUSE THEY
COME FROM SITUATIONS NOT OF
THEIR FAULT NOT OF THEIR
CHOOSING BUT MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO FIND A
PATH FORWARD. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THAT THANK YOU SO WITNESSES FOR.
WELL GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSE AGUILAR. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING JENNY HOUSE OF THE
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY SIX OR
EIGHT.
OF FOR THE PAST THIRTY FIVE
YEARS JENNY HOUSES THAT FORMER
FOX YOUTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
HELPING THEM IN ROLE IN GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE.
AB TWENTY SIX ONLY REFLECTS ONE
OF JENNY HOUSES LONG STANDING
VALUES WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE
CLOSEST TO AN ISSUE OF UNIQUELY
SUITED. TO DRIVE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS.
ALTHOUGH OVER NINETY THREE
PERCENT OF FOSTER YOUTH ASPIRE
TO GO TO GET A COLLEGE DEGREE.
ONLY THREE PERCENT OF THEM WILL
EARN A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
AND LESS THAN ONE PERCENT.
WE'LL GET A MASTER'S OR
DOCTORATE DEGREE.
PEOPLE OF LOOK THROUGH THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HAVE UNIQUE
INSIGHT. ON THE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT DRIVE SOCIAL
WORK.
COMBINING THE PERSONAL LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF A FOX YOU CAN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. WITH A
GRADUATE SOCIAL WORK DEGREE
WOULD ENABLE THEM TO NOT ONLY
GIVE BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
BUT WAS SENT IN THE FIELD AS A
WHOLE.
AB TWENTY SIX VOICE SEEKS TO
CREATE A CLEAR PATHWAY. FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE LIVED THROUGH THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEMS TO BECOME. A
LEADER IN THE FIELD OF SOCIAL
WORK.
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE THE
LOAN REPAYMENT GRANT FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR FOSTER YOUTH. AND
WILL PRIORITIZE THEM IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR THE
LICENSE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
PROVIDER DUCATION PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF FOSSIL QUALIFY FOR
UNDER THE CURRENT PROGRAM.
AND TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SYSTEM PAYING OFF THEIR SCHOOL
LOANS.
BY MAKING THESE CRUCIAL
INVESTMENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE. ITS
COMMITMENT AS A LEADER IN SOCIAL
WORK TO THE LIVES OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN FOSTER CARE. T IS FOR
THESE REASONS THAT WE'RE URGING
SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY SIX I.
THANK YOU DISH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MIKE'S TO
DIRECT.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MIKE SEGURA I
HAVE A PHD COMING FROM FOSTER
CARE.
I WANT TO START ONLY THIS EASY
FOR YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
EXCEEDINGLY SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
GIVEN THAT OVER HALF OF.
TRANSITION AGE FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH ARE YOU THERE. AT DESTINED
FOR HOMELESSNESS OR A. YOUNG
CORPORATION SYSTEM.
AS THE ONE PERCENT THAT DO GO ON
TO GET GRABBED AGREES.
FIFTY PERCENT PERCENT OF THEM
GOING TO WHAT THEY CALL THE
HELPING PROFESSIONS.
THAT'S PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC
POLICY LIKE MYSELF.
SOCIAL WORK THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO IT'S A MINUSCULE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT I SEE THIS IS
SOMEWHAT ROUGHLY ANALOGOUS TO
SORT OF A TEACH FOR AMERICA
MODEL. WHERE IF THEY PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM THEY'RE GOING TO
BE?
OBLIGATED TO SERVE AS A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF YEARS IN SOCIAL WORK
WHICH IS A FIELD THAT I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE OF HAS EXTREMELY
HIGH TURNOVER LOW INCENTIVES.
SO WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IF YOU GO TO A MASSIVE VIOLENCE
SHELTER.
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK THERE ARE SURVIVORS.
IF YOU GO TO A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
CENTER.
MANY OF THE WORKERS THERE ARE
SURVIVORS.
THAT EXPLAINS PART OF THE
PHENOMENON OF WHY.
FORMER PROSECUTOR SO MOTIVATED
TO GO INTO SOCIAL WORK.
AGAIN IT'S AN EXCEEDINGLY SMALL
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE AND THAT'S
GONNA TRANSLATE TO A DROP IN THE
BUCKET IN TERMS OF THE FISCAL
IMPACT.
I DO WANT TO SHARE THAT.
THERE ARE NO. FUNDING PROGRAMS
SUPPORT FROM THE FROSTY THING
GRAD SCHOOL.
AS A GRAD STUDENT MYSELF I WAS
COMPETING WITH THE SAME YOU KNOW
FUNDING AS EVERYONE ELSE THERE
ARE NO ANALOGOUS THINGS LIKE
CALGARY ENERGY TO GRANTED THINGS
LIKE THAT.
FOR FORMER FROSTY THROUGH OUR IN
GRAD SCHOOL SO ANYTHING THAT CAN
INCENTIVIZE THEIR SERVICE. OUT
APPRECIATE A SUPPORT ON THANK
YOU.
THEY DO VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEM NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
QUESTIONS ARE COMING FROM KEY
MEMBERS. MISSTATEMENT AND THEN
MR.
THANK YOU SO I NOTICE YOU HAVE
NOBODY.
YOU DON'T HAVE NAY LICENSED
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS HERE
WITH YOU SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
TRUE.
OKAY UP AND IT WOULD JUST BE
REMISS OF ME NOT TO SAY AS A
LCSW THAT YOU ARE. US IF THERE
ARE THERE ARE SOME PROGRAM THE
TITLE FOR THE PROGRAM WHICH WE
HAVE THAT ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO
WORK IN AN CHAO PROTECTIVE
SERVICES AND AND PAYS FOR A
PORTION OF THEIR. GRADUATE
SCHOOL A AS WELL AS NAME PLACES
THEM IN IN FUEL PLACEMENT
SPECIFICALLY IN. A. JOB OFFER
AGENCIES.
.
AND THAT IS THAT IS STATE FUND
THAT TEACH FOR AMERICA THAT IS
ALSO FUNDED BY A GENERAL FUNDS.
SO YOU ARE IT IS IT JUST ME OR
DOUBLING THE FEES YOU ARE
DOUBLING THE FEES ON A
POPULATION A DEMOGRAPHIC WHO HAS
CHOSEN TO GO INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE.
DOES NOT MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
AND SO IT.
I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
AND BECAUSE SOCIAL WORKERS AND
ENCOUNTERS ARE NICE PEOPLE I
DON'T THINK YOU SEE ANYBODY
HERE.
BUT IF THEM I WOULD TO SAY IF
WE WERE DOING IT TO REAL ESTATE
AGENTS TO ANYBODY ELSE
I WOULD IMAGINE THERE WAS A
RECENT BOOK SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION WHEN YOU. DOUBLE.
THE FEE FOR ONE TO RENEW ONCE
LICENSE.
IT AND THAT IS A VERY GOOD POINT
THAT YOU MAKE WE ACTUALLY
REACHED OUT TO SEE BECAUSE OF
COURSE THE TEST WAS THERE THEN
THIS NO OPPOSITION FROM THAT
GROUP. I WOULD NOT HAVE BROUGHT
THIS IF THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONSTERNATION.
POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN.
THESE ARE WORKERS THISIS A
COMMUNITY WHO ABSOLUTELY CARES
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT THEY SERVE
THEY ARE UNFORTUNATELY WILLING.
TO SEE THIS DOUBLING DEFEATS
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EXISTING
PROGRAM AND WHAT WE'RE ALL WE'RE
DOING REALLY HERE'S EXPANDING
IT.
THEY WERE WILLING TO DO THAT.
AND AYE WAS HATED THAT MAKES ME
WANT TO GO FIND ANOTHER FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THIS ABSOLUTELY DOES.
BUT WE HAVE THE FUNDING SOURCE
WE HAVE THE PROGRAM. OVER REALLY
DOING IS EXPANDING AT.
FROM A POPULATION WHO IS WILLING
TO HELP.
I WOULD YOUR POINT I WOULD.
I WOULD HOPE THAT OTHER. AREAS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EXPANDING
HE'S ESPECIALLY WHEN WERE
ADDRESSING A SMALL POPULATION.
WHO REALLY NEEDS US TO STAND UP
FOR THEM THAT THEY WOULD BE THE
SAME LEVEL OF WILLINGNESS? TO
HELP AS WE ARE FROM THE FOLKS
FROM HOME WE ARE ASKING FOR THE
CITIES ARE VERY SENSITIVE TO
THAT QUESTION. AND THAT'S WHY WE
DID THAT OUREACH TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WAS NOT GOING TO BE
ANY OPPOSITION TO IT.
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT THRILLED.
BUT THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND.
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE UP FOR.
A LOT OF A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE VALUE BASED IF WE REALLY DO
VALUE THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THEN THEM WE SHOULD FIND.
DIFFERENT WAYS TO PAY FOR IT
THINK CONTINUING A TO TO CHARGE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE
WORK. YES AND IT THIS THIS
WASN'T ALREADY EXISTING PROGRAM
MAYBE WE SHOULD PROPOSE THAT
MAKE UP A BUDGET ASK I'M HAPPY
TO DO THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
WITHIN.
THE STRUCTURE THAT WE HAD
BECAUSE THOSE ARE USUALLY THE
EASIEST BILLS TO GET THROUGH.
BUT THE SIZE THE POPULATION THE
BENEFITS THAT THIS PROVIDES
GETTING SOME OF THESE KIDS INTO
GRADUATE SCHOOL AND.
AND REALLY HELPING THAT BROADER
POPULATION IS IS ABSOLUTELY A
LOT OF LOCAL SO WE DO WORK WITH
THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE. AND.
HAPPY TO EXPLORE OTHER WAYS OF
TRYING TO PUT EVEN MORE MONEY
INTO THE PROGRAM. THAT HIS
SUCCESSFUL LIKE THIS AND HAS THE
BENEFITS THAT IT DOES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M SURE I'M
NO QUESTION BY ONE I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR YOU
SO DESIRE THANK YOU UNTIL I KNOW
THAT YOU WORK IN THIS IN THIS
SPACE ROUTE FOSTER CARE. AND SO
OF AYE.
IS CERTAINLY MORE THINK YOU'RE
SPEAKER OF FOR ONE.
SHARE HIS TESTIMONY BECAUSE
CERTAINLY SAID AS AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW FOSTER YOUTH HAS POOL THEIR
SELVES UP BY THE BOOTSTRAPS AND
DONE SOMETHING SUCCESSFUL. AND
RISEN TO A LEVEL OF HAVING A
DOCTOR DEGREE IN THIS PARTICULAR
FIELD AS OF THAT'S WE WANT TO DO
IS TRY TO ENCOURAGE. OF THOSE
WHO THE FOSTER SYSTEM BUILT
BECAUSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
RECEIVED. A NUMBER OF JUST BEING
DRAMATIC
JAZZ.
AND JUST THE WHOLE SITUATION
BEING A FOSTER KID AND. FACING
THOSE OPPOSITIONS.
AND GIVING AVE OPPORTUNITY THAT
ALL THE REST OF THE KIDS HAVE
INSERTED THIS BILL DOES THAT AYE
WHEN COMMEND YOU ON IT. AND
AGAIN WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE COOPER OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER GIPSON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAKER.
THANK YOU I WOULD JUST IN THEM
WHY CLARIFY TO SAY THAT I DON'T
THINK I HEARD YOU SAY THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. IT'S STILL THE CASE
THE CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION FOR
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
OPPOSES THE BILL TODAY.
REMOVE STATUS IT WAS NO
OPPOSITION BUT WE REACHED OUT TO
THE FOLKS WHO WOULD BE PAYING
THIS AND THEY ARE NOT. THEY ARE
NOT OPPOSED TO IT THERE HAS BEEN
SOME CONCERNS RAISED BECAUSE
WERE PRIORITIZING FOSTER KIDS.
AND BOTH FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
WE'RE GIVING THEM A STIPEND WE
ARE PRIORITIZE IN THEM. YES WE
ARE IN THIS CASE THIS IS A
POPULATION THAT DESERVES. A LEG
UP WE PRIORITIZE THEM FOR
ENROLLMENT IN COLLEGES WE
PRIORITIZE THEM FOR FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION GETTING THEM INTO
GRADUATE SCHOOL GETTING THEM TO
COMPLETE.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO TO GET
BACK INTO IN THE FIELD AND AND
GIVE BACK IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT I'D THERE ARE PLENTY OF
NEED FOR?
SOCIAL WORKERS I DON'T THINK
THIS WILL IMPACT OTHERS WHO WANT
TO GET IN THE FIELD BECAUSE IT'S
A SMALL POPULATION AND GIVING
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY AND SOME
SOME HOPE. IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT I THINK YOU AND I
THINK IF YOU COMMITMENT TWO.
WAYS IN WHICH THE STATE CAN HELP
FOSTER YOU THINK I'M JUST ALSO
MINDFUL OF THE CONSTITUENTS OF
MINE WHO ARE PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST IF THEY IF THEY MAY
END UP PAYING THIS BUT.
I I THINK YOU FOR THAT AND
APPRECIATE.
THE.
.
YOUR FOCUS ON ON FOSTER CHILDREN
I I'M JUST VERY CONCERNED WITH.
THE FEEL AND AND WHO CAN ACCESS
THAT AND THEN I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE JUST CLEAR ON THE RECORD IF
YOU
STILL REMAINING TO POST.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE
BAKER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
DON'T YOU WISH CLOSE I ASK YOU
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THIS DOES ENJOY A NIGHT
RECOMMENDATION THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR WHICH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
RUSSIA'S DE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS LOUTH AYE LOW AYE
BRO. BRO NOW ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER NOW BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG UP VOTING GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
TING AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR STONE A
BELIEVES THAT WILL OPEN TRAPS
NUMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ON NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE.
JUST AS A REMINDER WILL ALLOW UP
TO THREE MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT AND UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE WELCOME PLEASE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I MISTER
CHAIRMAN BORIS.
AS MOST OF YOU BY NOW KNOW THAT
I HAD MY DAUGHTER VIA C.
SURROGATE.
AND WHEN I MET MY SURROGATE WE
HAD THIS GREAT CAMARADERIE AND
AS WE WERE I WAS WALKING BACK TO
MY CAR SHE SAID OH AND BY THE
WAY. I LIKE TO HAVE MY CHILDREN.
WITH THE MIDWIFE.
AND ICE NODDED AND I SMILED AND
I WALKED TO THE CAR AND I GOT TO
THE CAR AND I THOUGHT TO MYSELF
WHAT IS A MIDWIFE.
I HAD NO IDEA.
BUT I SOON LEARNED.
MIDWIVES ARE EXTRAORDINARY.
AND WORKING WITH ONE IS AN
ENRICHING AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXPERIENCE.
I.
PEOPLE ASKED ME WHY I'VE BEEN SO
COMMITTED TO THIS ISSUE THREE
AND A HALF YEARS LATER HERE I
AM.
AND ALL I CAN SAY IS THIS.
HOW DO YOU SHOW RESPECT FOR THE
PERSON WHO GAVE THEIR BODY?
SO THAT YOU COULD HAVE THE
GREATEST GIFT OF YOUR.
YOU MAKE SURE THAT SHE ALWAYS
HAS THE CHOICE WHEN IT COMES TO
HER BODY. HOW SHE CONTINUES TO
GET THAT GIFT?
SO LIKE I SAID HERE I AM. THE
THIRD YEAR IN A ROW.
FOR WHAT I BELIEVE WILL BE THE
LAST TIME. IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AND SO I THINK YOU GUYS FROM MY
AUNT FOR YOUR INDULGENCE OVER
THIS LAST THREE YEARS.
BUT WE ARE AT A TIPPING POINT IN
CALIFORNIA.
RISING HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE
TO BURDEN WORKING PEOPLE.
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE IS NOT A
REALITY FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
THERE ARE TWO OPTIONS.
WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO DO NOTHING
AND LET MARKET WORK ITSELF OUT.
OR WE CAN TAKE IMMEASURABLE
ACTION TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
BETTER.
WE CAN GIVE PEOPLE FIGHTING
CHANCE TO SEE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS.
WE CAN ENSURE ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE IS NOT JUST A POLITICAL
TALKING POINTS.
BUT AN ACTION THAT WE ARE TAKING
AND WORKING TOWARDS.
LIKE I SAID EARLIER I SPENT MY
LAST THREE YEARS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATOR FIGHT LEGISLATURE
FIGHTING TO ALLOW CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE TO USE THEIR
SKILLS. THEIR TALENTS AND THEIR
TRAINING TO MAKE OUR SYSTEM
BETTER.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IT
TAKES TO BECOME A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE.
BECOMING A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE IS NOT EASY.
IT TAKES MANY STEPS INCLUDING
GRADUATING FROM A NURSING
PROGRAM.
PASSING THAT AND KLAX AND BEING
IT LICENSE DOES A REGISTERED
NURSE.
AFTER THEY BECOME A REGISTERED
NURSE THEY MUST ATTAIN A
MASTER'S DEGREE OR HIGHER IN
THEIR SMITH THREE. AND MANY OF
THOSE PROGRAMS REQUIRE ONE OR
MORE YEARS OF NURSING EXPERIENCE
TO GAIN ADMISSION.
ONCE THEY HAVE BECOME A
REGISTERED NURSE GAIN EXPERIENCE
COMPLETED A GRADUATE LEVEL
PROGRAM UNEARTHLY WE'VE NOW THEY
MUST PASSED THE NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION EXAM IN NURSE
MIDWIFERY.
AND AFTER THE HAVE BECOME AND
REGISTERED NURSE GAIN
EXPERIENCE.
A GRADUATE LEVEL.
PASSED THE NATIONAL EXAM THEY
MUST APPLY AND E APPROVED BY
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSE
FOR ADVANCED PRACTICING NURSE
LICENSURE IN CERTIFIED NURSE MY
FURRY. MIDWIFERY.
AND AFTER ALL THAT THE READY TO
GO TO WORK SPECIALISING IN
WOMEN'S HEALTH AND MATERNAL
CARE.
WE HAVE NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE MOST OTHER STATES
ALLOW CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES
TO PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY WERE
ONE OF ONLY SIX STATES THAT
STILL REQUIRE PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION.
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES CNN TO
PRACTICE UNDER THE SUPERVISION
OF A PHYSICIAN BUT SPECIFIES BUT
THATS SUPERVISION REQUIREMENT
SHALL NOT BE CONSTRUED TO
REQUIRE THE PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF
A PHYSICIAN.
AND I WANNA REITERATE THAT. THE
PHYSICIAN IS NOT PHYSICALLY
PRESENT DURING BIRTH UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
ALTHOUGH THE SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENT HEATHER C. N. N.'S
TO PRACTICE ONLY ONE WHERE A
PHYSICIAN CAN SUPERVISE IT DOES
NOT CONSIST OF ANY ACTUAL
OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY.
INSPECTION A REVIEW OF CHARTS
CO SIGNATURES ON PRESCRIPTION
DIRECT CARE OF THE PATIENT OR
EVALUATION OF CNN PATIENTS AT
ANY POINT DURING PREGNANCY OR A
WELL WOMAN CARE.
IN COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
OBSTETRICIANS OR GYNECOLOGIST
THE SUPERVISION REQUIRED LIMITS
ACCESS TO CARE FOR WOMEN EVEN
WHEN A SENATE CNM IS AVAILABLE
TO PROVIDE CARE.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO KNOW IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN NO IT WAS APPROVED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR TO REMOVE
PHYSICIAN'S SUPERVISION OF
LICENSED MIDWIVES.
UNLIKE LICENSED MIDWIVES
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE A GRADUATE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION. IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR LICENSURE AND YET
ARE STILL SUBJECT TO PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO CREATES
A LEVEL OF PARITY IN LAW.
BETWEEN ISLANDS AND CNN'S BY
REMOVING THE PHYSICIAN'S
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENT FOR
CNN'S.
ALLOWING THEM PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY WITH IN THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
I ASK THE SERGEANTS TO PASS OUT
A SIDE BY SIDE COMPARISON OF C.
N. N.'S AND AND IT EL ENDS
REGULATORY BODIES. AN EDUCATION
SO THAT YOU HAVE IT.
IN ADDITION AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TO SPECIFY THAT CNN SHALL
CONSULT WITH AND IF NECESSARY CO
MANAGE REFER TO OR TRANSFER CARE
TO ITS POSITION INSURGENT IN ANY
OF THE FOLLOWING SITUATIONS.
IF THE CURRENT CONDITION IS BE
ON THE CNM SCOPE OF PRACTICE
BASED ON EDUCATION IN
PREPARATION.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT A
CONDITION OR DISEASE LIKELY
JEOPARDIZES THE HEALTH OR LIFE
OF THE NEWBORN OUR MOTHER.
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES AND PET
PERSONNEL ARE NOT AVAILABLE IN
THE SETTING OF CARE.
PREGNANCY IS NOT A HIGH RISK
MEDICAL CONDITION.
LOOK PERMITTED TO WORK TO THE
FULL EXTENT OF THEIR EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE CNN'S CAN EXPERTLY
MANAGE MORE PERSON CALIFORNIA.
I'M TELLING CNN FROM PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENT WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR THOUSANDS OF WOMEN
IN BOTH URBAN AND RURAL AREAS.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO IS A
GOOD STEP TO GIVE CALIFORNIA'S
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE AND IT IS
IMMEASURABLE ACTION TO MAKE OUR
SYSTEM BETTER.
WE HAVE HAD GREAT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDER MEETING HIS.
A WITH THE OPPOSITION AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
LIKE I SAID FOR FLORA. ALLOWING
TO ME TO BE BACK HERE AGAIN YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND HOPEFULLY THIS IS
THE LAST TIME IN THIS COMMITTEE
YOU WILL HEAR FROM ME. WITH THAT
UP TO DATE WE HAVE HOLLY SMITH
THE CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE AND
DR ANNETTE FEINBERG OBGYN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND TO AND.
SUMMER BURKE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TESTING OR GIVE
FOR FOR A HUG NO HASHEM.
YOUR.
QUITE PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AGAIN FROM AT AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC UP TO
THREE MINUTES TOTAL FOR
TESTIMONY SUPPORT THESE WHEN
EVERY READING.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS HOLLY
SMITH I AM A NURSE MIDWIFE IN
THE CO CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
POLICY COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION.
NATIONWIDE POLICYMAKERS AND
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON THE
MATERNITY CARE CRISIS. CURRENTLY
THE UNITED STATES HAS THE WORST
MATERNAL DEATH RATE AMONG ALL
COUNTRIES IN THE DEVELOPED
WORLD.
IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE MADE SOME
AMAZING PROGRESS IN REGARDS TO
DEATH DURING PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH.
DESPITE THIS BLACK WOMEN ARE
STILL DYING AT A RATE THREE TO
FOUR TIMES THAT OF WHITE WITH.
CAESAREAN SECTION IS NOW THE
MOST COMMON HOSPITAL SURGERY AND
PRETERM BIRTH THE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH OF CHILDREN UNDER FIVE
IS INCREASING AND CALIFORNIA
AFTER YEARS OF DECLINE.
ADD TO THIS CRISIS THE SEVERE
AND WORSENING SHORTAGE OF OB
CHAINS THROUGHOUT THE STATE NINE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE NO
OBSTETRICIAN AT ALL NINETEEN
COUNTIES HAVE FIVE OR FEWER.
AND THERE HAS BEEN NO INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF OBSTETRICIANS
TRAIN SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY.
TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM EIGHTY
TWO SIX EIGHT TWO SIX TO REMOVE
THE SUPERVISORY TETHER FROM
NURSE MIDWIFERY PRACTICE.
SO THAT WE CAN GO WHERE WE ARE
NEEDED.
AS OTHER STATES HAVE PROVEN
PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION DOES NOT
IMPROVE SAFETY NOR OVERSIGHT.
THE DATA CLEARLY REVEALED THAT
RURAL AND HEALTH PROVIDER
SHORTAGE AREAS FOR SUFFERING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
WE ARE FAILING WOMEN AND BABIES
IN THESE AREAS.
YOU COULD EVEN SAY THAT OUR
UNWILLINGNESS TO INTEGRATE NURSE
MIDWIVES TO IMPROVE THE
MATERNITY CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
IN THESE PLACES THAT NEED IT
MOST IS IN FACT HARMING WOMEN.
MY HOPE TODAY IS THAT YOU WILL
SEE THE URGENCY OF THIS CRISIS.
TO SIMPLY CONTINUE AS WE ARE
ESSENTIALLY MEANS WE ARE OKAY
WITH THE STATUS QUO. WHAT DOES
THAT SAY ABOUT HOW WE VALUE
WOMEN AND FAMILIES?
NURSE MIDWIVES ARE THE HIGHEST
EDUCATED AND MOST WELL TRAINED
MIDWIVES IN THE WORLD WE EXCEED
ALL INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS WE
HAVE LOWER MATERNAL AND INFANT
DEATH RATES LOWER PRETERM BIRTH
RATES LOWER SYRIAN RATES.
BECAUSE WE FOCUS ON PREVENTION
AND WELLNESS BE.
WE TYPICALLY WORK IN LOW
RESOURCE AREAS AND WITH MEDICAID
POPULATIONS WHERE ONE WOULD
EXPECT TO HAVE POOR OUTCOMES BUT
THIS IS NOT SO WITH NURSE
MIDWIFERY.
IF YOU HEAR ONE THING TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PLEASE HEAR
THIS.
THE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT FOR
NURSE MIDWIFERY FOR AT THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT FOR NURSE
MIDWIFE'S MAKES A DIFFERENCE
WITH PATIENT OUTCOMES THERE IS
NOW A ROBUST COLLECTION OF
STUDIES THAT SHOW TIME AND
AGAIN.
THAT STATES THAT PROMOTE IN
INTEGRATE MIDWIVES INTO THEIR
SYSTEMS OF CARE AND DO SO WITH
FEWER REGULATORY RESTRICTIONS
LIKE PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION HAVE
BETTER MATERNAL AND NEONATAL CAO
CAO FORTY SECONDS LEFT THEY HAVE
A HIGHER PROPOSED PROPORTION OF
NURSE MIDWIFE ATTENDED PERSON
RURAL HOSPITALS AND. HAPPY
LARGER NURSE MIDWIFE WORKFORCE
THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR WE CAN
HELP THE HEALTH PROVIDER
SHORTAGE AND WE CAN IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF WOMEN AND BABIES IN
THE STATE.
SO LET'S LET MIDWIVES GO WHERE
THEY ARE NEEDED MOST AND START
THE HARD WORK OF CREATING
HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES THE
SHOWING WOMEN AND BABIES OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY ARE VALUED
AND THAT THEIR HEALTH MATTERS NO
MATTER WHERE THEY ARE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL ONES IS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT HERE AT THE
TABLE.
BUT MANY INTERNET FOR MY NAME'S
ANNA FEINBERG I'M AN
OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGIST THAT
SUTTER IN DAVIS.
.
AND I'VE EVER BEEN IN PRACTICE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND
I'VE WORKED WITH NURSE MIDWIVES
AND AND MOSTLY IN THE HOSPITALS.
SINCE THAT TIME. I'VE FIRST
THEY WORKED IT OUT BROWN IN A
TEACHING HOSPITAL AND OVER TO
THIS SMALL COMMUNITY HOSPITAL IN
DAVIS AND ALSO VERY MUCH.
PARTNER THAT CONCLUDES OUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONCLUDE.
YES I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
CONSULTING A COLLABORATION IS
IMPORTANT BUT SO SUPERVISION IS
NOT. REQUIRED.
AND I'D ALSO SAY THAT I'M
AMERICA THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
SUPPORTS INDEPENDENT PRACTICE
BIG YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME INFLATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO ORNAMENTS TURNED
MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING ROXY IN GOLD
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
PAT WHALEN ELSE MOST NEXT HERE
ON BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA PROUD
MEMBER ASKED ME RICHER SUPPORT.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE F.
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MCKEE
REPRESENT THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
AND I COXON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCACY IN
SUPPORT.
I'VE BEEN ALL TOMORROW BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND SUPPORT.
KELLY BROKE SOME BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS HERE IN SUPPORT.
MONICA MILLER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION NURSE
ANESTHETISTS IN SUPPORT
THINKING.
DR BJ SNOW ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BIRTH
CENTERS AND I SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND HOPE YOU WILL TOO.
REBECCA GARRETT BROWN PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AND A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE FOR OVER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS. AND THE
PHYSICIANS AT UCSD MEDICAL
CENTER AND THE NURSE MIDWIVES TO
THE LARGE COLLABORATIVE
PRACTICE.
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI ANGIE ARIELLE ACTUAL MIDLIFE
WE ON THE GROUND TWENTY YEARS
THOUSANDS OF BABIES.
IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND.
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GEORGE MILLER ABAFT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY DISH NO
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NOW LIKE
TO WELCOME UP MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
KINDLY COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND AGAIN UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBEDIENCE
DISTRICT NINE AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS. AND I WON'T NEED.
THREE MINUTES I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THE THREE AND
HALF YEARS HAVE.
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS AND THEY
TRULY WERE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
AND THE BILL IN PRINT WE ARE
STILL OFFICIALLY OPPOSE THEM
ONCE AMENDED. BUT I DO BELIEVE
BASED ON OUR MEETINGS WE WILL
GET THERE AND I THINK BY THE
NEXT COMMITTEE WE WILL BE ABLE
BE ABLE TO SAY THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL SO THANK YOU THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. WHICH IS LIKE
TELLING MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE AND SAY THAT.
WE ARE. STILL OPPOSE MUST
AMENDED.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US TO.
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY WOMAN
EGGMAN BOOK I THINK I JUST
WANNA.
CONGRATULATE AUTHOR AND THANK
HER FOR HER.
DETERMINED. AND GRITTINESS IN
GETTING THIS THROUGH I AM VERY
PROUD AND OPEN UP THE BEAR
WITNESS TO THIS JOURNEY WITH
YOU.
AND I'M GLAD TO BE OF THE VOTE
FOR THIS ONE MORE TIME.
BUT YOU'RE MUCH ASSEMBLY WHEN
BAKER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND.
THOSE ARE TEARS OF STRENGTH I
HAPPEN TO KNOW THAT EVE
DEMONSTRATED ITS JUST FIERCE
DETERMINATION AND PARTICULARLY
WHEN SOMETHING AFFECTS.
CHILDREN AND LIFE AND COMING
INTO THE WORLD SO.
CONGRATULATE YOU JUST MIGHT
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY KNOWS THOSE
ARE ABSOLUTELY TEARS OF
STRENGTH.
I'VE NOT ALWAYS SUPPORTED THE
EFFORTS TO CHANGE THIS IN PRIOR
YEARS WE'VE GOTTEN CLOSE BUT
HASN'T BEEN THERE BECAUSE I DO.
I'D I'D I DO BELIEVE THERE IS
THERE IS GOOD THAT COMES FROM
HAVING A PHYSICIAN RELATIONSHIP
THAT IS MORE FORMALIZED.
BUT YOU HAVE DONE GOOD WORK ON
THIS. AND I I I DO TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY KNOWING THAT THE
THERE ARE EFFORTS AFOOT TO. GET
COMPLETELY THERE FOR MANY.
AND.
ONE OF THE. REASONS WHY IS I I
APPRECIATE.
THAT IN.
IN SITUATIONS WHERE THERE ARE
HIGH RISK BIRTHS.
THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN AT AND LEGAL IN OUR
LAWS INCOME ALMOST ENCOURAGEMENT
TO HAVE THAT.
.
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE DOCTORS
AND THE MIDWIVES AND AND I SAY
THAT IF SOMEONE HAD A HIGH RISK
PREGNANCY OF.
TWINS THAT WERE BOTH BREACH I
HAD CANCER BACKGROUND A WHOLE
LITANY OF THINGS FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO TODAY I WAS ON BED REST WITH
TWINS THEY ARE HAPPY HEALTHY
KIDS AND I AS A MOM.
SOON TO BE MOM WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I COULD PICK
WHAT WAS GOING TO BE THE
ABSOLUTE BEST WAY TO BRING MY
KIDS AND TO THE WORLD WITH THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF SUCCESS. AND
THAT INCLUDED HAVING ACCESS
I HAD A PARENT IT ALL JUST. BY
AYE THERE IF IF I HAD FELT THAT
A COMBINATION OF PARASITOLOGIST
IN A MIDWIFE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
BEST WAY TO GO I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO PICK THAT. AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT OTHER CALIFORNIANS HAVE
THAT GREATER ACCESS.
AND WE'VE AS YOU POINTED OUT
VERY WELL HAVE ALREADY.
SEEN RULES DIFFERENT I MEAN THE
LACK OF PARITY WITH LICENSED
MIDWIVES IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE SO. I THINK YOU FOR
CONTINUING ON THIS AND GETTING
IT TO A POINT WHERE MANY MEMBERS
WHO IN THE PAST IF.
FOR REASONS STRICTLY RELATED TO
POLICY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET
THERE WITH YOU TO PLEASE TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. AND.
.
APPRECIATE THOSE TEARS OF
STRENGTH.
BUT YOU'RE BROKE. NEIGHBORS
CHAIR.
HIS BURQA.
ACLU ONCE SAID IT'S DEJA VU ALL
OVER AGAIN.
EITHER WAY ON ALL YOUR PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE
THAT IF A WOMAN'S COMFORTABLE
GOING TO A MIDWIFE THAT SHOULD
BE HER CHOICE AND SO I ALWAYS
SUPPORTED YOUR CONCEPT THAT. I
REALLY JUST WANT TO SAY.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR HARD
WORK I MEAN I THINK IT'S GOING
TO PAY OFF.
DISMEMBER THE MEETING LAST YEAR
WHERE WE WERE.
BUT YOU DESERVE SOME CREDIT
PUSHING THIS FORWARD INDIAN
STRONG AND WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITE
DRESSING THEIR CONCERNS.
AND.
I'LL THE SPORT AGAIN TONIGHT
GRADUATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CONGRATULATIONS ON ALL THE. ON
THE PAY FROM ALL THE HARD WORK.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
STILL SOME ISSUES THAT ARE
REMAINING AND SOMETIMES.
AS WE GET CLOSE THE FINISH LINE
OF THE TOUGHEST TO RESOLVE. UPS
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
STAY ENGAGED AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE FINAL
RESULT I'M AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
WASN'T BEFORE SO.
I'M HAPPY TO BE THERE BE ABLE
TO MOVE THIS BILL ALONG AND TO
HOPEFUL THAT I'LL BE ABLE TO
VOTE I WOULD GUESS TO THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NO DIFFERENT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY WOMAN BURKE DO
WISH TO CLOSE. SENATE YES PLEASE
I I WANNA THINK THE OPPOSITION
FOR THE HARD WORK AND YES WE'VE
HAD SOME.
.
A STRONG WORDS THAT WE HAVE
EXCHANGED BY IT'S BEEN WORTH
IT'S BEEN WORTH THE CHALLENGE.
I THINK EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE IF LIKE I SAID AGAIN
FOR CONTINUING TO STICK WITH ME.
TOOK FOR A LOT FOR TELLING ME
YOUR CONCERNS FOR LETTING ME
WORK THROUGH THEM OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. AND I THINK THE
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE FOR
STICKING WITH ME. AND THEY ARE A
COLLABORATIVE GROUP.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE WITH DOCTORS. AND
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO BE DURING
THIS PROCESS THROUGH THE REST OF
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BECAUSE YOU HAVE
HEARD FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
RECOGNITION OF YOUR TENACITY.
AND YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS
ISSUE AND.
IT IS CERTAINLY AN AUTHOR THAT
TO MEMBERSHIP BE PROUD OF SO WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
VERY A HEARTFELT TESTIMONY. AND
NO WITH RESPECT SO THIS DOES
ENJOY AND I RECOMMENDATION.
AND THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND COMMITTEE SECURE WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION AS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW AYE
BRO. BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
THAT HAS TWELVE THOSE WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
BLOOM BURKE.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON THEN TO.
.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY.
AND THAT IS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE THAT IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT TEN.
MISTER IRVING YOU HAVE TO A TWO
BILLS HERE FILE I'M THEIR
FIFTEEN ENVIRONMENT SEVENTEEN IF
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT TEN.
AND IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING VIEW
YOUR STAFF THAT YOU WOULD WISH
TO PRESENT ONLY.
BY I LIKE TO TAKE THE SECOND
BILL FIRST SURE YEAH ACTUALLY SO
THAT'S A FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE SIXTY EIGHT IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S RIGHT GREAT. SO AGAIN
MEMBERS OF THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AS IN THE BILL
TWENTY NINE SIXTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MARIN THE V. IN THE STANDS HAVE
ENJOYED AYE AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I THINK YOU
TURN MEMBERS CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO PREPARE AND
DISSEMINATE. AND INFORMATIONAL
BROCHURE FOR VICTIMS OF
PSYCHOTHERAPIST PATIENT SEXUAL
IMPROPRIETY TITLED PROFESSIONAL
THERAPY NEVER INCLUDE SACKS
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY WOULD
UPDATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS INFORMATIONAL
BROCHURE. IN ORDER TO BETTER
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON THE
PROHIBITION OF SEXUAL BEHAVIORS
IN THERAPY.
THE BILL REMOVES OBSOLETE
LANGUAGE INCLUDES CURRENTLY
RECOGNIZE FORMS OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND MODERN MODES OF
COMMUNICATION.
IT ALSO MORE CLEARLY ARTICULATES
TO CONSUMERS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
COURSE OF ACTION
WHEN REPORTING THESE TYPES OF
ALLEGATIONS HERE TO TEST FIND
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY.
IS DOCTOR MCHAEL ERICKSON.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW AND
VICE CHAIRMAN GROW AND ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
ASSEMBLYMAN LEVINE.
UP MY NAME IS DOCTOR MICHAEL
ERICKSON. AND I'M HERE TODAY AS
A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY.
WHICH IS ACTIVELY SUPPORTING
THE AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY EIGHT.
THE OF BOARDS MISSION IS TO
ADVANCE QUALITY PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
BY ENSURING ETHICAL AND LEGAL
PRACTICE BY LICENSED
PSYCHOLOGIST AND SUPPORTING THE
EVOLUTION OF THE PROFESSION.
OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IN LICENSING
AND REGULATING PSYCHOLOGISTS
REGISTERED PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSISTANCE IS
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
.
I COULD SAY JUST A FEW MORE
THINGS ABOUT THE. A PROCESS THAT
LED UP TO THIS IF WE HAVE TIME
FOR THAT IT WOULD TAKE A FEW
SECONDS.
SURE FEW SECONDS PLEASE.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
BOARD BEGAN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE NEED TO UPDATE THE CONTENT
OF THE DC A BROCHURE. THAT IS
TITLED PROFESSIONAL THERAPY
NEVER INCLUDES SEX.
AND YET LOOK SOMETHING LIKE THIS
THIS IS THE ONE THAT WE'RE
HOPING TO UPDATE THROUGH.
.
ASSEMBLYMAN WHO LOOKING THIS
LEGISLATION.
WE'VE MET WITH THE OTHER
LICENSING BOARDS WITH THEM
HEALTH CARE A BIT INVOLVED
MENTAL HEALTH.
AND OF.
DEVELOPED OF SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT UP HERE
BECOME NOW THE.
ITEMS THAT ARE IN AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY EIGHT.
.
THE BILL AS WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
UPDATE AND MODERNIZE STATUTORY
PROVISIONS RELATING TO THE D. CA
INFORMATIONAL BROCHURE THE ONE
THAT I WAS JUST PULLING UP.
.
BY REMOVING OBSOLETE LANGUAGE
AND INCLUDING LANGUAGE THAT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT TO.
THINGS THAT HAVE DEVELOPED WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA SUCH AS SIXTEEN OF
WHICH IS INAPPROPRIATE AND NOT
WELL COVERED.
IN THE CURRENT BROCHURE.
AND THE BILL WOULD ALSO ADD A
NEW THRESHOLD FROM ON A
PSYCHOTHERAPIST IS LEGALLY
PROVIDED REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE
BROCHURE TO A CLIENT.
SO THE BOARD ASKS.
AND THINKS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LIVE
BEING AND. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF
HERE FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY EIGHT AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
IBOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK.
YEAH JENNIFER SAW MOST OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD STAFF WORK WHO
WORKED AT THE BORDER PSYCHOLOGY
ON LANGUAGES IN THIS BILL WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AN ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SEEN NONE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION AT.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CONSUMERS AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY WOULD MEAN DO WISH TO
CLOSE. OUR SUFFERS FROM ABOUT
THE DO VERY MUCH IN THIS DOES
ENJOY AND AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION
THAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECULAR WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW
EYEBROW.
BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
AT THAT HAS ELEVEN VOTES AND
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR SHARING
NUMBERS BIG YOU VERY MUCH.
A SUMMER MOVIE NOW IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT TEN BUT IT'S
OUR STANDING AT LEAST PROCESS
AND A TESTIMONY TODAY BUT NOT
SIMPLY VOTERS THAT CORRECT YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CLARE.
WE GOT A.
CALIFORNIANS WHO TRAVELED.
FROM NEAR AND FAR TOO I TO
SHARE TESTIMONY AND I WANTED TO
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY OTHERS
A LOT OF. INTEREST IN THIS BILL
AND WANTED TO HAVE IT AIRED.
IN NO WAY THAT YOU CAN ASK
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
EIGHT TEN TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA SUN GROWN CANNABIS
COMMISSION. AND CALIFORNIA
INDOOR GROWN CANNABIS COMMISSION
SINCE THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS VOTED TO
AUTHORIZE THE CREATION OF MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS.
TODAY NINETEEN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE INDUSTRY
THEY PRESENT REPRESENT INCLUDING
LAST YEAR'S BILL AUTHORIZING THE
SPINY LOBSTER INDUSTRY TO FORM A
COMMISSION.
I GET JOB ON THAT ONE.
PROP SIXTY FOUR MADE CANNABIS
ILLEGAL CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS
SON GROWN CANNABIS FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN
ANY FARMER UN I REPRESENT THEY
ARE CONCERNED WITH MARKET SHARE.
GOVERNMENT REGULATION COSTS AND
SUSTAINABILITY WHILE THEY GROW
THE SAME PRODUCT THE INDOOR
CULTIVATORS FACE VERY DIFFERENT
ISSUES BOTH SEGMENTS CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE STRUCTURE. OF AN
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSION.
THE SUN GROWN CANADA A
COMMISSION WILL REPRESENT
OUTDOOR CANNABIS FARMERS WITH
EITHER AN OUTDOOR OR MIXED LIGHT
LICENSE FOR
STATE.
THESE ARE THE TRADITIONAL SMALL
FAMILY OPERATIONS
MANY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN FARMING.
FOR DECADES.
THE INDOOR COMMISSION OR
REPRESENT INDOOR CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS IN CALIFORNIA INDOOR
CULTIVATIONS REPRESENT EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. THEY HAVE A
NUMBER OF REGULATORY AND MARKET
ISSUES THAT COULD BE ADDRESSED
BY THE COMMISSION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO A FEW
ISSUES RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS.
FIRST IS THE.
CONCERNED THAT THE COMMISSIONS
ARE NOT APPROPRIATE THIS TIME
BECAUSE CANNABIS CULTIVATION IS
A PARTICULARLY VOLATILE SECTOR.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT CDFA.
STATES THAT THE NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ACT THAT LED TO THE
CREATION OF COMMISSIONS
WAS ESTABLISHED AND I QUOTE. TO
BRING STABILITY TO AGRICULTURAL
MARKETS.
IN ADDITION THE GROWERS IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WILL HAVE
FINAL SAY ON ESTABLISHING A
COMMISSION.
WHEN IMPLEMENTATION VOTE IS PUT
BEFORE THEM.
AS YOU'LL HEAR FURTHER TODAY
FROM FARMERS THEMSELVES THE TWO
COMMISSIONS.
ARE NEEDED FOR TO HELP THEIR
NEEDS TO HELP MEET THEIR
CONCERNS.
AND ULTIMATELY ALSO WHY CREATE
TWO COMMISSIONS FOR THE SAME
CROP.
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS WHY THE
COMMISSION STRUCTURE WAS CREATED
N LAW.
COMMISSIONS CAN BE DESIGNED TO
pFARMERS PAIN THE ASSESSMENTS.
IN THIS EXAMPLE SON GROWN IN
INDOOR CULTIVATORS GROW THE SAME
CROP.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE.
BUT WE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
ISSUES IT MIGHT AS WELL BE TWO
DIFFERENT CROPS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE RESEARCH NEEDS GROWING
PRACTICES MARKET CONCERNS AT
SARAH. WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AB TWENTY TEN AND ASSURE
TESTIMONY IS CHRIS NEVIN LL
PRESIDENT OF INTERNATIONAL
CANNABIS FARMERS ASSOCIATION AND
A FORMER HERSELF.
AND MARVIN PINEDA WHO HAS BECOME
HALF OF THE INDOOR CANNABIS
INDUSTRY
I ALSO HAVE LOUIS BROWN. EYES
WITH AN EXPERT ON AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THE
STRUCTURE IN HISTORY OF THESE
ENTITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
UP TO THREE MINUTES OUR
WITNESSES WISH LIST BEGINS
PLEASE.
GREAT THANK YOU.
.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN AT ALL AND I
WANT TO JUST THINK EVERYONE FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO.
HERE COMMENTS REGARDING AB
TWENTY TEN ST I'M AYE LIVING
BARBERVILLE WHICH IS IN HUMBLE
COUNTY AND I'M A LONG TIME
MEDICAL CANNABIS FARMER. AS ONE
OF THE CO FOUNDERS OF THE
EMERALD GROWERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
SERVE.
ON THE BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WHERE I CHAIR THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE FOR CCI A.
AND THEN.
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
MENTIONED I'M THE FOUNDING CHAIR
OF THE INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ASSOCIATION.
IN SHORT I HAVE SPENT MOST OF MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE.
SUPPORTING BEST PRACTICES FOR
SOME GROUND CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS.
.
YOU KNOW THIS BILL IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO US A SON CROWN A
COMMISSION WITH SUPPORT OUT TORN
EXPLAIN TIER ONE FARMERS.
WE'D DO YOU CURRENTLY MAKE US
PROBABLY EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
CULTIVATORS IN THE STEAMY YET WE
ONLY REALIZE AROUND TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE MARKETPLACE.
THAT'S KIND OF FLIPPED ON ITS
HEAD AMERICAN WILL SPEAK TO THAT
A LITTLE BIT.
INDOOR CULTIVATORS ARE A
SMALLER PERCENTAGE OF
CULTIVATORS THE SPEEDS IN THE
STATE BUT YET MAKEUP AROUND
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE. MARKET
SHARE CURRENTLY IN THE REGULATED
MARKETPLACE.
THE PRIMARY REASONS FOR KEEPING
THESE TO COMMISSION SEPARATE IS
THAT THE RESEARCH THE REGULATORY
NEEDS AND RELIEF THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENTS THAT COULD COME OUT
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN A
COMMISSION ARE INCREDIBLY
DIFFERENT BETWEEN. SONG GROWN
FARMERS AND WOOD INDOOR FARMERS
NEED.
WHAT WE NEED FOR RESEARCH IS
MUCH MORE BEAST IN THE ROUND OF
APPELLATION OF ORIGIN?
ENVIRONMENTAL IN WATERSHED BEST
PRACTICES I'M LEARNING HOW TO
OPERATE WITHIN THE CARRYING
CAPACITY OF THE LAND SO THAT WE
CAN.
SUSTAIN OURSELVES ON OUR
HOMESTEADS WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
CALLED TO BE MEAN FOR DECADES UP
POINT. AND ALSO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT FROM A REGULATORY
PERSPECTIVE IS WE HAVE
EXPONENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS COMPARED TO INDOOR
CULTIVATORS WE ARE SUBJECT TO
THE WATER RESOURCE BOARDS.
AGRICULTURAL DISCHARGE PROGRAM
AND WE ARE SUBJECT TO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S I'M LAKE CONSTRAIN
BAD AGREEMENTS.
AND THE FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE IN THE OWNERS NATURE OF
THOSE ARE INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
FOR MOST OF THESE SMALL SCALE
OUTDOOR IMMENSELY TIER ONE
FARMERS ONCE YOU ENCLOSE
CULTIVATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE NO LONGER
SUBJECT TO THOSE REGULATIONS SO
INDOOR CULTIVATORS ULTIMATELY
BEING IN IN CLOSE I MEAN ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THOSE REGULATIONS WE
HAVE DIFFERENT REGULATORY NEEDS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND THE
RESEARCH IS DIFFERENT AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND SO.
INSURED MAYBE I JUST WANT ALSO
MENTION THAT.
THE CULTIVATION THAT HAPPENING
TEN SECOND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THINGS YOU APOLOGIES FOR GOING
OVER.
.
IS AN ECONOMIC BACKBONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND UNLESS WE CAN
STABILIZE THESE CULTIVATORS BY
BRINGING THEM INTO A REGULATORY
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR THEM LONG
TERM WE WILL LOSE THAT ECONOMIC
BACKBONE. WE WILL LOSE THESE
FARMERS AND SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME.
TO DISCUSS THIS BILL ON THE
NEED FOR IT TODAY THINKING OF
GREAT ANY ADDITIONAL ME TO USE.
JUST ABOUT REALLY QUICK MOMENT
BEEN OUT THE NIGHT KIND AS
BUSINESS ALLIANCE PERCENT MEAN
HOWEVER HUNDRED DISPENSARIES
HIGH. THEY NEED WE WE NEED A
COMMISSION AND WHERE COMPLIANCE
WE. WANT WE HAVE THEIR FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESS AND WE HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WE NEED TO STATUS
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR OUTSIDE
GROWERS. AND THIS IS THE BILL
THEY HAVE YOU CAN SEE I THINK
ANY ADDITIONAL ME TO USE.
PLEASE.
HI AM PRECISE HE'S SENT ME TO.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE UNIT INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ASSOCIATION HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE REGARDING THE
STRUCTURE THE INTENT IN THE
PURPOSE OF AN AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES VISION IS
BECOMES PART IN INFLATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GRANT MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CM VEHICLE EVEN SAN JOSE ONE
OF THE LARGEST CULTIVATORS IN
THE STATE INDOOR. I'M WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL AFFECT THE FUTURE
SUCCESS OF THIS INDUSTRY THANK
YOU.
I MUST NOT COMEY HAVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT.
WHICH MILLER AMERICAN ALLIANCE
FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS
AND SUPPORT WE NEED THE
CULTIVARS. TO BE PROTECTED FOR
THE PATIENTS IN THE STATE THANK
YOU.
WARDING HER HAPPY MEMBERS SAID
JASON BRIGHT CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS TO ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION. WOULD DO HAVE
MEMBERS WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
TIMING THIS BILL SO WE ARE IN
FACT NEUTRAL AB APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEM NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVING GIVES TO
CLOSE OFF YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY IN IN HEARING ABOUT
THE GREAT NEED.
HERE WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
DISPENSARIES IS THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY RUNNING OUT OF CANNABIS
THAT THE.
CULTIVATORS OF CANNABIS ARE NOT
NOT ABLE TO GET LICENSE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW WHAT THE BEST PRACTICES
ARE AND WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS
THAT CULTIVATORS FARMERS. WANT
TO BAND TOGETHER.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THROUGH
THIS REGULATORY PROCESS AND BE
ABLE TO LIFT THEMSELVES OUT OF
THE SHADOWS AND INTO THE
REGULATED MARKETPLACE AND OUT OF
THE BLACK MARKET. THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN EXISTING AND FOUR OUT FOR
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE CREATED
AYE HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE NEED TO AS
LAWMAKERS ASSIST THEM. TO BE
ABLE TO OPERATE LEGALLY.
AND IF AND IF THEY ARE ASKING US
TO HELP THEM OPERATE LEGALLY A
WE REALLY MUST REACH OUT BACK TO
THEM.
TWO OUT TO HELP LIFT THEM UP I
RATHER THAN PUTTING A FAMILY
FARMS OUT OF BUSINESS AND
HURTING THE LOCAL ECONOMIES
ORDER. PUSHING THEM FURTHER INTO
THE SHADOWS AND CONTINUING.
WHAT WAS A MARKETPLACE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO CHANGE AND BRING
BACK OUT BRING INTO A SYSTEM
WERE ABLE TO TAX IT AND MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE SAFE? THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
HOPE TO BRING THIS BACK TO YOU
SOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
MYSELF
AND SO I'LL JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU AT THE PODIUM AND HAND THIS
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR
.
GOOD MORNING.
TO THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
WHICH WOULD HELP TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING AND LET ME FIRST START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY JOINT AUTHOR AS
WELL AS HIS STAFF FOR HIT THEIR
EXPENSIVE WORK WITH THAT WITH
OUR OFFICE.
IN OUR STATE AT THIS TIME ALMOST
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE CLOSE TO
ONE IN THREE ADULTS HAVE AN
ARREST OR CONVICTION RECORD. AND
OUR STATE HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
RECIDIVISM RATES IN OUR COUNTRY.
ONE OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF
RECIDIVISM. ARE THE EXTRA
EXTENSIVE CHALLENGES THAT FACE
EX OFFENDERS TO GET A JOB UPON
REENTRY.
SPIKE BAN THE BOX POLICIES.
AT THE SAME TIME NEARLY THIRTY
PERCENT OF ALL OF OUR STATES
JOBS REQUIRE A LICENSE
A CERTIFICATE WORD APPROVAL BY
OVERSIGHT BOARD OR AGENCY FOR
ALMOST EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
DIFFERENT OCCUPATIONS.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS FACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS
WHEN SEEKING A LICENSE TO WORK?
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS WERE
DENIED A LICENSE EVEN THOUGH THE
PRIOR ARREST FOR CONVICTION IS
OLD. UNRELATED TO THE JOB OR
OTHERWISE DISMISSED BY THE
COURTS.
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH
LICENSING THAT GIVES THESE
CALIFORNIANS A FAIR CHANCE
AS IS THE CASE IN A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATES.
BY PROHIBITING THE DENIAL
REVOCATION OR SUSPENSION OF A
LICENSE ON THE BASIS OF A NON
VIOLENT CONVICTION THAT IS OLDER
THAN FIVE YEARS. OR DISMISS
CONVICTION OR A NON CONVICTION
ACT
UNLESS IT IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE DUTIES OF THE PROFESSION FOR
WHICH THE APPLICATION IS MADE.
FOR ALL LICENSES UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WHICH REGULATES ALMOST FORTY
MAJOR PORTS OR BUREAUS.
OUR BILL WOULD REQUIRE PORTS TO
COLLECT AND PUBLISH DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA ABOUT WHO IS DENIED A
LICENSE OR IS HAD A LICENSE
REVOKED OR SUSPENDED.
THIS BILL ALSO PROHIBITS BOARDS
FROM ACQUIRING AN APPLICANT TO
SELF DISCLOSE CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION THAT CAN ALREADY BE
OBTAINED THROUGH DOJ BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
LET ME KNOW THAT ARE BILL
REFERENCES THE TWENTY THREE
CRIMES THAT ARE CONSIDERED
VIOLENT UNDER STATE LAW AND
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE CONSIDERED
BY A LICENSING BOARD.
IF THE INTENT OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS REHABILITATION
WE NEED TO WALK THE WALK WE
CAN'T SAY WE WANT TO
REHABILITATE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEN BLOCK THEM FROM ACCESSING
JOBS WHEN RELEASED. WHICH IN
TURN LEADS TO MORE RECIDIVISM
AND MORE CRIME WITH THAT LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO OUR JOINT AUTHORS
MR LA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR AND FOR ALLOWING A
ASSEMBLY WHICH UNITED JOINT
AUTHORED THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
WHICH FOCUSES ON THE EFFORTS OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE PROVIDE. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS TO.
GET BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SET UP A
FRAMEWORK AND WHICH RECESS ALLOW
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BE SET UP FOR
SUCCESS AN OPERA. IN THIS SCENE
CHO THE CELLS MUCH OF THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
LET'S TURN OVER TO OUR WITNESSES
FROM THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER AND LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
JAIL.
OTHER GOOD EVENING OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHAIR AND AND OTHERS.
WE THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
THIS BILL TODAY I'M MY NAME'S
JOHN MAYER COME WITH THESE MAKE
ME LOS INNER AND WE WORK WITH
OUR CLIENTS ON A REGULAR BASIS.
WHO HAVE?
CRIMINAL RECORDS AND WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK
TOGETHER THEY'VE MOVED ON FROM
THEIR PAST AND THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD AND WHAT
WE'VE SEEN ON THE GROUND OF.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IS THAT THE
CURRENT LIE LICENSING LAWS AND
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOCK THEM.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND IN MANY
CASES EVEN IF THEY GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND ARE SUCCESSFUL
W. RESTRICTED LICENSE WHICH WILL
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY GET A JOB. IN THAT
FIELD.
ANOTHER CASES.
THEY ACTUALLY WON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SUCCESSFULLY GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS BECAUSE YOU
NEED HELP FROM AN ATTORNEY UP IN
MANY CASES TO NAVIGATE THIS
STUFF. SO.
THAT'S WERE SEEN ON THE GROUND
I'M WERE ALSO SING THE DATA THIS
BILL IS BASED ON DATA.
WHAT THE DATA SHOWS US NATIONAL
PLAN ALLOW PRO PROJECT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO?
FOUND OUT THAT BASICALLY AFTER
SIX YEARS.
AFTER SOMEONE'S BEEN.
OUT THERE LESS LIKELY THERE'D
THERE'D JUST ABOUT THE ONLY
MARGINALLY MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT
A CRIME THAT ANYONE WITH NO
CRIMINAL RECORD AT ALL I'M WE
ALSO FOUND.
THAT ACCORDING TO ARIZONA STATE.
UNIVERSITY STUDY THAT STATES
THAT HAVE.
LICENSING POLICIES THAT ALLOW
PEOPLE ARM COMES OUR STATE RIGHT
NOW THAT HAVE LICENSE BECAUSE
WHAT WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE A NINE PERCENT HIGHER
RECIDIVISM RATES.
AND THOSE WHO HAVE A LIFE AND
POLICIES THAT ALLOW PEOPLE
CRITICAL CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
HAVE A TWO POINT FIVE PERCENT
LOWER RATE EACH YEAR SO.
DATA SHOWS US THAT THIS IS THE
WAY THAT WE SHOULD BE GOING AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM MOST PC WILL
SHARE SOME MORE STORIES GOOD
MORNING I'M EVER DALLAIRE STAFF
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PERSONS WITH CHILDREN. WE DO
CLINICS ONE DAY CLINICS HELPING
PEOPLE CLEAR THEIR RECORDS ALL
OVER THE STATE AND I MEET
CLIENTS REGULARLY WORKING TO
CHANGE THEIR LIVES IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THEIR. STE THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES OFTEN THESE
CLIENTS WANT JOBS IN ORDER TO
GET.
WHAT JOB IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES IN THOSE
JOBS REQUIRE AN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE?
CURRENTLY I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
TELL CLIENTS WE CAN CLEAR THEIR
RECORD BUT THOSE SPORTS OFTEN
STILL CONSIDERING TONIGHT PEOPLE
BASED ON DISMISSED CONVICTIONS.
I WAS IN THE FRESNO RECENTLY
WORKING ON OF.
A CLINIC AND I WAS WORKING WITH
A CLIENT WHO IS A YOUNG MAN HE
WAS STILL IN COLLEGE AND HE
WANTS TO DO PASSED CONTROL A JOB
THAT REQUIRES AN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE. AND SO ALTHOUGH HIS
RECORD HAD IN FACT ALREADY BEEN
CLEARED HE WAS COMING BACK TO
SEE IF THERE WAS A WAY TO CLEAR
IT SO THAT HE COULD GET THAT
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE.
I'D LIKE THIS BILL TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT HIM AND I'M GETTING A
JOB THAT WILL SUPPORT HIM AND.
YOU KNOW SOMEDAY HIS FAMILY
SIMILARLY I WORKED WITH A WOMAN
WHO HAS A CALLING TO BE A
PRACTICING NURSE.
AND SHE HAD TO FIGHT FOR TWO
DECADES IN ORDER TO LIVE THAT.
LIVE THAT CALL AND TO BE ABLE
TO PRACTICE AGAIN BECAUSE OF A
PRIOR CONVICTION AND THE
LICENSING RESTRICTIONS.
I'M GOING TO HIGHLIGHT ONE MORE
JUST REALLY QUICKLY I'VE.
WORKED WITH A MAN WHO. WAS
HIRED AS A LOS PREVENTS
PREVENTION OFFICER. BUT BECAUSE
HE COULDN'T GET THE LICENSE THAT
COMPANY KEPT HIM IN TRAINING
STATUS SO HE WAS MAKING SEVERAL
DOLLARS LESS PER HOUR THAN OTHER
PEOPLE DOING THE EXACT SAME
WORK.
AND THAT COMPANY HE COULDN'T GET
THE LICENSE BECAUSE OF A
CONVICTION HISTORY. US OF THOSE.
AT OUR CLINICS PEOPLE WHO.
DISPROPORTIONATELY HAVE BEEN IN
JAIL OR ON PROBATION I JUST
WANNA ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE MANY
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE PRISON
SYSTEM THAT IS OUR TRAINING
PEOPLE TO DO THESE JOBS THAT
LATER REQUIRE. AN OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSE THIS IS FROM CDC OURS
WEBSITE THEIR REENTRY PROGRAMS
INCLUDE CONSTRUCTION TECHNOLOGY
CARPENTRY DRYWALL MASONRY
PLUMBING INDUSTRIAL PAINTING
ELECTRONIC ELECTRICAL.
CONSTRUCTION COSMETOLOGY MACHINE
SHOP HEATING VENTILATION AIR
CONDITIONING REFRIGERATION SHEET
METAL WELDING ELECTRONICS
NETWORK CABLING ROOFING
SUSTAINABLE LANDSCAPE DESIGN.
OFFICE SERVICES AND RELATED
TECHNOLOGIES COMPUTER ILLITERACY
AUTO MECHANICS ENGINE SERVICE
AND REPAIR SMALL ENGINE REPAIR
REPAIR AUTOMOTIVE BODY REPAIR
AND REST FINISHING.
I I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE DOING
THIS WORK ACROSS THE STATE WE'VE
SEEN PEOPLE LOOKING FOR A FAIR
CHANCE AT CAREERS AND WE NEED TO
FIX THESE RULES SO PEOPLE CAN
APPLY AND BE HIRED. FOR JOBS
THAT THEY'RE QUALIFIED.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THEY DO OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SPORT.
GOOD MORNING SABINA CROW CITY ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US ARE NINE BAY
AREA AND ALSO FROM LEGAL
SERVICES WITH PRISON FOR
CHILDREN AND WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND WE SUPPORT THE.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER REPRESENTING
TEN THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SAM WHO
ARE FORMALLY INVOLVED WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THANK
YOU AND SUPPORT.
ERICA ADDING GOING ON BEHALF OF
POLICY LINCOLN THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THINK YOU.
SENATE THE MIKE ON BEHALF OF THE
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
AND A COALITION OF OVER FIFTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE SUBMITTED LETTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU TO SHOW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE
OF THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RICHARD
MARCUSSEN ON BEHALF OF THE THE.
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS AND PLUMBING HEATING
COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE CERTAINLY NOT
OPPOSED TO A FIRST AND SECOND
CHANCES A PARTICULARLY FOR EX
OFFENDERS. IN FACT OUR
ASSOCIATIONS ARE AND SOME OF
THEIR.
MEMBERS.
WORK WITH CDC ARE ON PRE
APPRENTICESHIP IN CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION TO PREPARE
OFFENDERS FOR RE ENTRY INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION FIELD. HOWEVER
ARMED OPPOSITION STEMS FROM A
BELIEF THAT IN THE CASE OF
CONTRACTORS THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD IS DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB. OF OF THEIR FIRST
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND THE SECOND IS TO
ALLOW NEW ENTRANTS INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION FIELD AND AS HOME
IMPROVEMENT SALES PERSONS.
THEIR OWN RECORDS INDICATE A
THAT AND ONLY ABOUT ONE PERCENT.
OF POSITIVE HITS FOR CRIMINAL
RECORD A RESULT IN A OF AN
APPLICANT A FAILING TO RECEIVE
THEIR LICENSE SO NINETY NINE
PERCENT. OF THOSE.
APPLICANTS THAT DO HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD WHO APPLIED TO
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
ARE BEING LICENSED OR.
IT POTENTIALLY A A CONDITIONAL
LICENSE.
SO OUR CONCERN IS THAT.
THIS BILL IS A KIND OF A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL IT DOES NOT
REFLECT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE FORTY DIFFERENT BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE ALL UNDER
THE PART OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS. IT
WOULD TAKE AN EXISTING PROGRAM
THAT SEEMS TO BE WORKING WELL
BOTH FOR THE CONTRACTOR
COMMUNITY THE CONSUMERS AND THE
OFFENDERS WHO ARE APPLYING FOR A
LICENSE.
AND REPLACING IT WITH A A NEW
SYSTEM.
AT COST TO THE STATE.
AND A POTENTIALLY A DELAY IN AS
THEY IMPLEMENT THIS AND I GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF CREATING
THE NEW PROGRAMS TO EVALUATE THE
RECORDS.
THEY HAVE A STAFF THAT IS
DEDICATED A TO REVIEWING OF THE
APPLICANTS OTHER COME BACK WITH
A CRIMINAL RECORD A AND WE THINK
THAT THEY'RE DOING A AN
EXCELLENT JOB FOR THAT REASON
WERE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU DISH AWARENESS IS
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NOT BRING THAT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM. MS BAKER THANK YOU
AND THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL I THINK.
.
JUSTICE COMMITTEE LAST WEEKEND
PART TIME TO REALLY LOOK FOR
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN BE.
ENSURING THAT WE'RE NOT SEEING
THAT TOO MANY BARRIERS TO CAREER
PATHWAYS AND PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO WANT TO BEGIN AGAIN.
AND.
FOR WHOM WE NEED THE WORKFORCE
BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING MANY MORE
PEOPLE RETIRE AND LEAVE THE
WORK.
SO HERE'S THE THING THAT WE WE
DON'T WANT TO GO TOO FAR TO THE
OTHER SIDE SO I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT PROVISIONS THE
BILL HELP ME DECIPHER GOING.
WHERE WHERE YOU'RE GOING IF IT'S
TOO FAR ONE IS I KNOW THAT IN
ORDER FOR THE BOARD MY WENT OVER
SIMPLIFIED AND YOU THIS BILL TO
BE ABLE TO DENY? LICENSE
APPLICATION BASED ON A
CONVICTION IT NEEDS TO BE A
CONVICTION IS TO BE RELATED. TO
THE JOB FOR WHICH THEY ARE
REQUESTING LICENSE OR ADVERSELY
AFFECT THAT.
DOES PERJURY FALL INTO THAT.
.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT IF LINE.
IN A IN THE BUSINESS CONTEXT IS
RELEVANT TO THE PROFESSION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A CLINTON.
AND THAT WOULD BE UP TO EACH
BOARD TO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION
IT'S UNDER THE AUTHORITY THE
BOARD TO DECIDE WHAT TEMPLE LAWS
WOULD BE PERMITTED EN MI READ OF
IT WAS THAT PERJURY. IT'S IT'S
QUESTIONABLE EXPERTS QUESTION
AND I WOULD THINK THAT PERJURY
IS ONE THAT ABSOLUTELY SHOULD BE
IT SHOULD BE EXPLICIT THAT THE
BOARD. CAN MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION AND THAT'S WET
POPPED OUT IN MY MIND RIGHT AWAY
AND IF IF YOU'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THE BILL THAT WOULD BE
ONE THING.
ABSOLUTELY LOOK AT.
AND THE OTHER IS
VIOLENT FELONY.
I KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU
HAVE ADOPTING SOME OF THE
STATUTES.
IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY YOU'RE NOT
REWRITING THE LIST YOU'RE
ADOPTING OTHER PROVISIONS.
TWENTY THREE OR TWENTY FIVE
DEFINITIONS OF VIOLENT FELONY
WHICH I REPEATEDLY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH BECAUSE IT LEAVES
OUT.
SOME. CRIMES THAT ARE NOT
FELONIES ARE MISDEMEANORS
INCLUDING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VIOLATING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER. AND IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME TO BE LICENSED
IN AN AREA WHERE. YOU YOU ARE
REPEATEDLY VIOLATING A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER I
THINK THAT SHE
SOMETHING THE BOARD SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CONSIDERING EVEN HAVE AS
A BASIS FOR.
FOR SAYING NO YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
THERE YET YOU NOT APPROPRIATE
FOR THIS LICENSE BUT.
THEY'RE NOT CONSIDERED VIOLENT
FELONIES UNDER OUR LAWS
SOMETIMES.
.
THREATS OF ASSAULT TO A PEACE
OFFICER ALSO ARE NOT CONSIDERED
VIOLENT FELONIES.
AND SO THAT WAS CAN OFTEN BE TOO
NARROW A LIST I HAVE FOUND IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S TOO
NARROW WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT.
MANY OF OUR LAWS ARE SAYING WE
DON'T WANT THIS TO BE THE BASIS
IT SOUNDS VERY GOOD AND I'M I'M
SURE THAT'S HOW YOU DOING THIS
BUT IT OFTEN SOUNDS GET FOLKS TO
SAY.
I WE'RE MAKING SURE THE VIOLENT
FELONIES ARE PROTECTED.
THAT'S OFTEN A WEAKNESS IN THE
SECOND ONE IS IS IS IT A FELONY
FROM SOMEONE ELSE'S STATE.
SO LET'S SAY SOMEBODY COMES TO
CALIFORNIA APPLIES FOR A LICENSE
AND SOMETHING IS A VIOLENT
FELONY IN ANOTHER STATE BUT
ISN'T A VIOLENT FELONY HERE. AND
I'D I WOULD LOOK VERY CAREFULLY
AT THAT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE TIME THE.
HANDS OF THE LICENSE BOARDS TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS AND.
IT MAY I I MAY NOT HAVE READ IT
CAREFULLY BUT I DIDN'T POP OUT
TO ME.
AND THEN WHY FIVE YEARS FIVE
YEARS SEEMS PARTICULARLY.
THIS.
A SHORT TIME PERIOD YOU KNOW
BECAUSE ADULTS HAVE A A LIFE OF.
BEHAVIOR THAT WE CARRY WITH US.
WHAT BROUGHT YOU TO THE
CONCLUSION OF FIVE YEARS BEING
THE CUT OFF BECAUSE FOR ME
THAT'S THE DEBATE ON THE NARROW
SIDE PARTICULAR BECAUSE?
WITH SOME OF THE PRESSURE
PROGRAMS TAKES UP TO THREE YEARS
AND SOME OF THE OTHER TRAINING
AND SO SOMEONE TO BE IN A TRADE
FOR FIVE YEARS FAIRLY NEW TO IT
AND THEIR CONVICTION IS.
SO WE WERE TRIED STRUCK A
BALANCE IN THIS BILL.
ON THE ONE HAND.
WE THOUGHT THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
APPLY FOR A LICENSE RIGHT AFTER
CONVICTION THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE RIGHT THAT WOULD BE THE
ZERO MARK. ON THE OTHER HAND.
THE LONGER WE WAIT WERE TALKING
AGAIN ABOUT EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ONE OUT OF THREE
ADULTS WHO ARE EXCLUDED FROM
ALMOST THIRTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA JOBS THAT'S.
CHALLENGE WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS
FIVE YEARS FELT LIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE TO US.
I KNOW UNDER.
UNDER SOME STANDARDS.
DOJ.
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND OTHERS
IT'S MORE OF A SEVEN YEAR
STANDARD I'M OPEN TO
CONVERSATION THE COMEDIAN ALSO
SUGGEST THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING
FOR US TO DISCUSS BUT. BUT I
THINK FIVE YEARS FEELS LIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE AFTER SOMEONE'S
BEEN CONVICTED TO. OF HAVE PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY AYE AND
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD IF THEY
HAVE IT RE OFFENDED.
AND THERE'S NOT A SUBSEQUENT
CONVICTION I THINK THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS OUGHT TO TO HAVE A
CHANCE AND SO IT IT IT IS A
ADMITTEDLY BALLOTS BUT.
IS ONE THAT SEEM TEMP TO MAKE
SENSE IF THE GOAL OF OUR SYSTEM
IS TO TRY TO PREVENT INDIVIDUALS
FROM RE OFFENDING. WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS LET'S GIVE THEM A
JOBLESS GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET A LICENSE TO HAVE A JOB
YOU WANNA TAKE A MOMENT AND AND?
AND.
ADDRESS YOUR ISSUE AROUND THE
DEFINITION OF OF VIOLENT CRIMES
YES WE DIDN'T WANT THIS BILL TO
BE THE SUBJECT OF A DEBATE ON
WHAT IS IN THAT CATEGORY AND NOT
SO. THIS BILL SIMPLY REFERENCES
THE DEFINITION OF WHAT UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE IS
CONSIDERED A A VIOLENT CRIME.
APPRECIATE THERE'S SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT SHOULD OR
SHOULD NOT BE IN THAT CATEGORY.
BUT WE THOUGHT THAT THAT MADE
SENSE WE WE DON'T WANT TO RE
LITIGATE THAT ISSUE HERE AND I
THINK I AM BECAUSE IT'S VIOLENT
FELONY. THERE ARE BUILT THEIR
VIOLENT CRIMES AND OTHER VIOLENT
JUST FELONIES AND SO THAT WOULD
BE ONE AREA THAT I'M AYE WE
CONSIDER THEIR MANY AREAS THAT
ARE NOW MISDEMEANORS THAT ARE
WORTH LOOKING AT. I'M AND
FINALLY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT HELPFUL
ANSWER THERE'S ONE MORE POINT
THAT SEEMS TO BE IT IS IN
DISPUTE HAVE WE HEARD FROM
OPPOSITION THAT NINETY NINE
PERCENT. OF THOSE WHO ARE
APPLYING FOR THESE LICENSES ARE
GETTING THEM REGARDLESS OF
PRIOR.
FELONY CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
COOPER CONVICTION THAT'S ONE
PERCENT THAT'S A FAIRLY NARROW
MOUNTAIN THAT THE THE BOARD YOU
DOING A GOOD JOB. YOU JUST
PRESENTED THE INFORMATION AND I
MAY HAVE HEARD AROUND ONE IN
THREE OR EIGHT MILLION ARE NOT
GETTING.
OR MAYBE COULD STATE AGAIN ARE
NOT GETTING A LICENSE FOR IT. I
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE SOURCES ARE
ON IT BUT.
I'VE HAD CONTRACTORS EMPLOYERS
IN MY BUSINESS IN HER MY
DISTRICT COME TO ME AND SAY WE
WE ARE. AGGRESSIVELY LOOKING FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE REBUILDING THEIR
LIVES BECAUSE WE NEED THE WORK
FORCE AND I'M NOT SEEN.
THE DENIALS AS MUCH IF YOU CAN
ADDRESS THOSE STUDENTS TO
STATISTICS THAT SEEM TO BE
COMPLETELY CONTRARY.
BECAUSE IT HELPS US GET A SENSE
OF HOW MUCH IS THERE REALLY A
PROBLEM SO LET ME LET ME BE
CLEAR ABOUT THE STATISTICS THAT
I REFERENCED SO WHERE ST ALMOST
EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
EITHER BEEN ARRESTED OR
CONVICTED SO THAT'S THE
POPULATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND THEN THERE ARE THIRTY
PERCENT OF ALL CALIFORNIA JOBS
REQUIRE A LICENSE OR CERTIFICATE
SO THAT'S THE UNIVERSE OF FOLKS
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE DENIED
ACCESS TO LICENSE NOW WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL NUMBERS
ARE.
IN PART BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THIS DATA AND ONE ASPECT OF THIS
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY COLLECT THE
STATUS OF THAT WE KNOW WHAT THE
RIGHT ANSWER IS. BUT I CAN TELL
YOU AND ASSURE YOU THAT THE MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THIS ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BECAUSE.
THEY ARE CONNECTED WITH
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TO ACCESS THESE OCCUPATIONS
BECAUSE OF THIS LICENSE ONE
FINAL THING I'LL JUST MENTION
IS.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS IF YOU VISIT
THEIR WEBSITE IT LIST TWENTY
CAREER OR TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS PROVIDED TO PRISONERS
FOLKS IN OUR SYSTEM. BUT
IRONICALLY MOST OF THESE VERY
PROGRAMS ONCE YOU GET OUT OF
PRISON YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY APPLY
FOR. A LICENSE IN THAT
PROFESSION
STRUCTURE IN COSMETOLOGY AUTO
REPAIR EXCEPT TRUCK
BECAUSE OF THE VERY SITUATION
WE'RE HAVING RIGHT NOW SO WE'VE
WE SET UP OUR CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM HOPEFULLY TRAIN FOLKS.
TO GET THESE JOBS AND THEN THEY
COME OUT AND THEY CAN'T SO HE
CAN'T APPLY FOR THEM AT ALL.
ARE THEY ARE THEY MAY NOT GET A
LICENSE
THEY MAY NOT GET A LICENSE OP
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT THE SPORTS CAN LOOK AT
IS VERY BROAD.
SO THE REALLY NO STANDARDS AND
WHAT WE'RE SAYING HERE IS FOR
THAT CATEGORY OF NON VIOLENT
OFFENDERS WHOSE CONVICTION IS
LONGER THAN FIVE YEARS. WE WANT
TO GIVE THEM A SHOT AND WE THINK
THAT THAT CATEGORY OUGHT TO
OUGHT NOT BE LOOKED AT.
AGAIN UNLESS THE CRIME FITS.
AND IS RELATED TO THE
PROFESSION
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT'S
HELPFUL I I THINK YOU HAVE A LOT
OF TERRIFIC PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL PARTICULAR THE NEED FOR
DATA. WHICH I THINK THIS.
DISCUSSION UNDERSCORES AS WELL
AS THE PRECISION ABOUT WHAT DATA
WE HAVE IF IT'S THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEING. DENIED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
APPLY FOR A LICENSE WHICH YOU
JUST MENTIONED ARE NOT IT'S JUST
WHAT IS REALLY CAUSING THE
DENIAL SO THAT WE CAN BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE PRECISE ABOUT
IT.
PARTICULAR BECAUSE THESE BOARDS
ARE FOR CONSUMER SAFETY FOR ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE FIRST AND
FOREMOST NOT. RESTRICTING PEOPLE
FROM COMING INTO THE FIELD I I I
CAN'T GET THERE TODAY ON IT HERE
BUT I HOPE I'VE GIVEN SOME
SPECIFICS THAT ARE WHERE
HOPEFULLY WOULD BE HELPFUL IS IF
THE BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE.
AND AND THAT WE CAN BE LOOKING
FOR SOME OF THOSE AREAS THAT WE
ALL AGREE ON THERE'S A LOT OF
CONSENSUS.
AND START THERE AND SEE IF IT'S
REALLY NECESSARY TO GO AS BROAD
AS I FEEL THE BILL GOES TODAY.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WORSE CHAIR
ARMS CERTAINLY I WANT TO SAY
THAT OF THIS IS EXCITING BILL TO
ME.
I REMEMBER WHEN.
FORMER SPEAKER EMERITUS KAREN
BASS WAS HERE AND SHE CARES IN
THE PRE SELECTED SLASH BECAUSE
PEOPLE WHICH WEREPRESENT. A WHO
GET OUT OF JAIL OR PRISON.
HAVE CERTAIN WAS DENIED
SPECIALLY THOSE IN WAS TO.
PURSUE A CAREER IN TERMS OF
BORROWING CUTTING HERE IS A
LEARNED THAT PARTICULAR TRADE
AND CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THE FIVE YEAR I THINK THAT THAT
SPEAKS TO.
A PARTICULAR A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT THIS CAN REALLY
HELP MOVING FORWARD.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL IN
CERTAIN WILL ASKS IF I COULD BE
A COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE EXPRESS
BUT AND. BUT AARON WHICH I
REPRESENT BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
DENIED AND.
CANNOT RECEIVE A LICENSE
I WANT TO DO THIS KIND OF WORK.
THEY DO IT ON THE GROUND.
AND YOU KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE COME WE WANT
WHEREBY DOES COME OUT OF SHADOWS
WE WANT THEM TO COME OUT OF THE
SHADOWS. AND BE ABLE TO DO IT IN
THE RIGHT WAY.
AND SO PAY THEIR TAXES.
NOT HAVING TO HIDE.
AND DO THE RIGHT THING TO
PROVIDE A SERVICE AND WHEN THEY
OPEN UP THEIR OWN BARBER SHOP
AND SO THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO I
KNOW PERSONALLY.
WHO'LL BE X. CERTAIN EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BILL THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE COST OF TO BRING HIS
BILL AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE. BUT THERE'S A
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN
AND A SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMAN
CHEN.
THIS YOU CHOOSE SHARE REFLECT
CLOSE.
I JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT.
AGAIN WE'VE BEEN WORKING AND
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH
PARTNERS CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND
WANT TO THANK OUR SO OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ENSURING
THAT WE ARE IN CONTINUE DIALOGUE
WITH THE BOARDS AND DCA.
AND LET ME JUST SAY APPRECIATE
THAT THE QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
HAVE JUST BEEN RAISED IN A LAST
WEEK.
THERE WAS A BILL ON THE OTHER
SIDE THE AISLE THAT DID ALSO TRY
TO ADDRESS THIS VERY SO TOPICS
AROUND OUR LICENSING SYSTEM AND
HOW WE CAN. MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS PARTICULARLY WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO GAINFULLY.
RECEIVE SOME EMPLOYMENT THROUGH
THAT SYSTEM AGAIN THE END OF THE
DAY IF WE ALL ARE TRUE TO THE
VALUE OF REHABILITATION WE NEED
TO WALK THE WALK AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT WE.
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO'VE DONE THEIR TIME HAVE A
CHANCE OF BEING ABLE TO
REINTEGRATE BACK INTO SOCIETY
WITH MANY OF THESE PROFESSIONS
AGAIN CLOSED EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
PROFESSIONS THAT IN OUR STATE
CURRENTLY REQUIRE A LICENSE.
CERTIFICATE OR OTHER APPROVAL
FROM AN OVERSIGHT BOARD WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. LOW EYEBROW.
BRUNO ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER NOW BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NOW GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
THAT IS SEVEN VOTES AND WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
FINAL ITEM.
AND THAT IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THIS IS A BE A THIRTY ONE. TEN
AS YOU.
AS YOU WILL RECALL.
WE HAD CRAP PRESENTATION.
LAST WEEK AND I IN RECOGNITION
OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
PRESENTATIONS OCCURRING.
FEE MY BILL TO LIMIT SOME OF
THAT.
TESTIMONY SO THAT WE CAN FULLY
ENGAGED AND FRUITFUL DIALOGUE SO
HAVING SAID THAT ASSEMBLY OR
MOMENT PLEASE PRESENT WHEN
EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR INDICATED
LAST WEEK I PERCENT AND IN FULL.
THE MERITS OF AB THIRTY ONE TEN
DO YOU AND DISCUSS MY TEN WITH
THE BILL I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING EXTENSIVELY
WITH US ON AMENDMENTS. TO
STRENGTHENING CLARIFY THE BILL
OVER THE PAST WEEK I'M ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS NOTED IN
THE STAFF ANALYSIS.
THE CHAIRS PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
REMOVE THE PROVISIONS THAT
IMPOSE LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS
FOR ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND STATE
CREATE A FRAMEWORK FOR
REGISTRATION AND TITLE
PROTECTION REQUIREMENTS FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
FOR THE RECORD WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DETAIL
RELATED TO THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
AND WILL CONTINUE OUGHT TO BE
BOB WORKING ON THOSE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD.
UPON APPROVAL OF THE BILL TODAY
IN ESSENCE IT IS MY OPINION THAT
A CONSUMER INJURED INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO CHOOSE
WHERE TO SEEK TREATMENT. AND NOT
BE LIMITED WITH CERTAIN OBVIOUS.
NOT BE LIMITED WITH CERTAIN
OBVIOUS LIMITATIONS AGAIN MY
PRIMARY GOAL WITH A. B. THIRTY
ONE TEN IS TO PROVIDE CONSUMER
PROTECTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER CERTIFIED AS
HAVING COMPLETED TRAINING IN THE
FIELD THAT THE CONSUMER HAS AN
AGENCY TO CHECK THE CREDENTIALS
AND HAVE A PLACE TO LODGE
COMPLAINTS IF THEY RECEIVE POOR
TREATMENT. NONE OF THAT EXISTS
TODAY CALIFORNIA REMAINS AN
OUTLINE AIR IN THIS REGARD AND
WITH THAT LET ME SIMPLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
DID YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN UP
TO THREE MINUTES FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING AND ONCE AGAIN MY
NAME IS MIKE JUST ARMED ATHLETIC
TRAINERS PHYSICAL THERAPISTS IN
HERE REPRESENTING THE.
CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND AS NOTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLINS I'M INTRODUCED A BILL
THAT WOULD LICENSE AFFLECK
TRAINERS.
AND WE HAD THE SUPPORT OF THE
CMA THE NC DOUBLE A NUMEROUS
PHYSICIAN GROUPS A CIF PARENT
ADVOCACY GROUPS.
AND BUSINESSES.
I BECAUSE.
ALL THOSE ORGANIZATIONS FELT
THAT IT HELP PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND ALSO WOULD REMOVE THE LEGAL
GRAY AREA THAT SURROUNDED THE
PRACTICE OF ATHLETIC TRAINING.
I'M AN INCREASE LIABILITY.
FOR THOSE EMPLOYERS OF ATHLETIC
TRAINERS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
LICENSURE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
METHOD OF REGULATING THIS ALLIED
HEALTH CARE PROFESSION.
BUT IN SPITE OF THIS BELIEF
CATIA'S HAS.
MADE A MAJOR CONCESSION IS
SUPPORTING THE AMENDMENTS
DRAFTED BY COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND EFFORT
THAT THEY SPENT. ON THOUGHTFULLY
DOING SO. AND WE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT AND IT WOULD HELP PROTECT
THE PUBLIC.
AND PREVENT FUTURE IS HE'S FROM
HAPPENING.
AND WE DO HAVE IS NOTED SOME
TECHNICAL AND CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE BROUGHT UP WITH THE AUTHOR
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND
APPRECIATE THEIR COMMITMENTS.
I'M TO ADDRESS THOSE.
AND THE CA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK
SUPPORT.
OKAY SEEM NOW MEMBER YES.
I THINK YOU AYE MISTER CHAIR.
WANT TOM SERBS IN CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON NANCY LOW COST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
AND ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ON THIS ITEM
SENIOR.
THIS MISTER CHAIR AHEAD OF BOB
MILLER REPRESENTING STANFORD
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SING NONE AT ANY
OPPOSITION TO ALLOW UP TO THREE
MINUTES AND AGAIN. WE PREVIOUSLY
HAD TESTIMONY LAST WEEK'S IF YOU
COULD KEEP YOUR COMMENTS PRECISE
PLEASE PRESENT WHATEVER READY.
TO MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SIR
KARL LONDON HERE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATIONAL TRY TO.
.
KEEP AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE THAT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
CONSIDERING. A FIRST OF ALL YOU
WANT I THINK YOUR STAFF.
VINCE CHIEF FOR THE WORK YOU
PUT ANY WAS.
VERY TRANSPARENT WORKING WITH
US WE APPRECIATE THAT. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE. IN
THE POSITION OF TRYING TO RE
WRITE A BILL THIS CLOSE TO.
HEARING DATE LIKE THIS BILL
ACTUALLY IS EVEN REAL IMPRINT.
AND SO WERE RESPONDING AS BEST
WE CAN WITH THAT WE HAD ALL FALL
WINTER THE FRONT END OF THE
SPRING TO TALK TO THESE ISSUES.
YET HERE WE ARE WRITING A BILL.
THE SHORT A NOTICE.
WE GET THE AMENDMENTS MONDAY
MORNING.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THEM WE
OVERALL STILL BELIEVE THAT. THE
TITLE PROTECTION CERTIFICATION
SCHEME IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE
WAY TO HANDLE THE ISSUES THAT
ARE RAISED BY THE AUTHOR THE
AUTHORS NOTED THAT HE'S
INTERESTED IN. MAKING SURE THE
ATHLETIC TRAINERS CAN TRAVEL
SUPPORT THEIR TEAMS ATHLETES IN
OF THE STATE'S.
AND MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO CALL THEMSELVES
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER. UNLESS A
PROPER CREDENTIALS A TITLE
PROTECTION CERTIFICATION WOULD
HANDLE THAT.
ALSO NOTE. THIS BEEN SAID OVER
OVER AGAIN THE WITH THE LAST THE
TO REGULATE ATHLETIC TRAINERS
THAT SON A SURLY TRUE WATER
STATES DO HAVE.
A TITLE PROTECTION CERTIFICATION
SCHEME.
I THAT USES THE NET
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WHICH IS
REALLY THE GOLD STANDARD IN
PROFESSIONAL AND COLLEGE SPORTS
ANYWAY.
THE BILL AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WE BELIEVE STILL HAVE
A LOT OF HOLES.
AS EXAMPLES OF JUST CITE A
COUPLE AGAIN WE'RE DOING THIS ON
SHORT NOTICE BUT IN SUBSECTION
FOUR OF THE SECTION DEFINES THE
SCOPE. THERE'S A SECTION THAT
SAYS THE ACTIVITIES THAT AFFECT
TRIGGERS ME BILL WILL DO IT SAYS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO. WE
SEE THAT IS A VERY OPEN DOOR FOR
ANY OTHER KIND OF ACTIVITY THEY
WANT TO DO.
THE PROTOCOL THAT'S REQUIRED AND
IS A MEMBER STE WHEN A PHYSICIAN
ATHLETIC TRAINER WE BELIEVE
SHOULD BE TIED TO THE SPECIFIC
ATHLETE. AND NOT WRITTEN AS THE
GENERAL PROTOCOL AS IT APPEARS
TO BE WHERE THE ATHLETIC TRAINER
CAN OPERATE.
UNDER ANY KIND OF.
RELATIONSHIP THEY HAVE TO HAVE
WITH THE PHYSICIAN.
THE DEFINITION MATH ATHLETIC
ACTIVITY STILL INCLUDES WHAT WE
WOULD DESCRIBE AS THE
RECREATIONAL ATHLETE.
FOR WHOM NO PRE PARTICIPATION
SCREENING A BASELINE IS REQUIRED
ARE KNOWN.
THE MEMBERS ALSO DO SOMETHING
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE I'VE EVER
SEEN BEFORE WHICH IS ALLOWED
THIS BOARD THIS CREATED.
TO TAKE MONEY FROM THE PRIVATE
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION OF THE
PROFESSION THAT IT'S INTENDED
OVERSEE. AS SEEMS VERY ODD TO
SEEMS AT A MINIMUM TO BE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
AND.
THE LAST THING WE SEE IS THE
PRACTICE IN THIS BILL THAT'S
BEEN DEFINED.
SHOULDN'T BE ONLY ATTACHED
ATHLETES IN SPORTS BUT TO ALSO
INCLUDE WE BELIEVE SPORTS
SETTINGS AND SPORTS VENUES.
AGAIN WE'RE DOING THIS ON SHORT
NOTICE WE DID AN EMERGENCY PHONE
CALL US NOT TO DO THE BEST WE
COULD BE RESPONSIVE. WE'RE.
OPPOSING THIS BILL WHEN ASKED
THIS BILL NOT BE MOVED FORWARD
IN THE WE INSTEAD. DO THIS
THROUGH A MORE CONSTRUCTIVE
APPROACH WE HAVE THE BILL IS NOW
WHAT DID THESE THINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL METERS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IVAN ALL
TOMORROW BEHALF THE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
IN THE AMERICAN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION. WE DO
REMAIN.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BUT
WE ARE.
THANKFUL FOR THE WORK THAT MR
GEE DID THE THE ONE THIRTY AM.
EMAIL THAT HE WE RECEIVED
VARIOUS.
I KNOW HE'S BEEN WORKING HARD
ON THIS ALSO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS WE ARE
ENCOURAGED.
THAT THE ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE
NO LONGER A ACCORDING TO THE
AMENDMENTS UNDER THE BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY WE DO STILL
SHARE SOME CONCERNS AS OUTLINED.
BY THE PHYSICAL THERAPIST WHEN
MR LONDON'S TESTIMONY.
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN I CAN ALSO
REPRESENT THAT.
MY LEADERSHIP AT A A T. A N.
ATTACK HAS BEEN AT A NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF THE REYES MUCH
WEAKENED AND THEY HAVE NOT HAD A
CHANCE TO. GET TOGETHER WE'RE
GONNA GET TOGETHER TOMORROW TO
REALLY PILE THROUGH THE
AMENDMENT SO THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN ADDITIONAL
WOODS IS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
CATHERINE LOSSES CARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS ARE SIMILAR TO THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WE HAVE
CONCERNS BOTH ON TIMING AND THEN
ARE STILL REVIEWING THE SCOPE
COMPONENTS THANK YOU.
MARK MCKINNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
JUST LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE CALIFORNIA.
THERAPY ASSOCIATION.
AND A PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION RATHER AND.
UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN OPPOSED
LESS AMENDED.
THAT WAY WHEN ELLISON WILSON AB
TO SEE HERE ON BEHALF OF UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ONE ECHO THE CONGRADULATIONS TO
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK AND AND ALSO TO THE
AUTHOR. BUT WE ARE STILL IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
CHRIS READ LICENSE PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS ANSWER BUT ATHLETIC
TRAINER I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK WAS PUT INTO THE BILL OVER
THE WEEKEND BY COMMITTEE AND
STAFF.
BUT STILL IN OPPOSITION.
LARA LOPEZ OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASON STATE.
JAMES SIMS PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
ATHLETIC TRAINER FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
RICKETTS PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION.
CELTIC ABOUT UP PHYSICAL
THERAPIST NCTA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS IN OPPOSITION.
PAUL SMITH PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
FRESNO CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION STILL UNLESS
FURTHER AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE FOR
HAVING MISSED YOUR PRESENTATION
MISTER MULLIN BUT TO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU ARE TAKING
THE. COMMITTEE OF MOUNDS OF I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
ON. TAKING CARE THE.
THOUGHT THAT THIS GROUP OF FOLK
PROVIDERS
WASN'T FOR.
A PARAMOUNT TO A CONCERN TO ME
SO I'M GLAD THAT.
OF THAT YOU FOUND ANOTHER WAY
TO.
TO HAVE SOME OVERSIGHT FOR UP
FOR THIS GROUP.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING AT THE LAST MINUTE
AND.
THAT THERE ARE STILL SOME
LANGUAGE DISCREPANCIES WHICH IS
KEEPING THE PANTIES IN THE OUT
HE'S.
FROM.
STATING GATHER THEIR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OF.
BUT I KNOW I KNOW YOU WELL
ENOUGH THAT I DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
ASK YOU IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON.
ON LANGUAGE IN TRYING TO
IMPROVE AND ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAVE THAT'S WHAT I'LL
BE LOOKING FOR IS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND. CONTENT TO A
SUPPORT AND VOTE FOR IT TODAY ON
BUT RESERVE JUDGMENT ON THAT
GETTING THOSE ISSUES WORKED OUT
TO AS TO WHAT I'LL DO WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME FOR.
ASSEMBLY. SEEM NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALAN DO YOU WISH
TO CLOSE.
JUST THE OF THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR YOUR
STAFF'S WORK ON THIS.
I KNOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
BY.
REGRET THAT SOME OF THIS CAME
TOGETHER A YESTERDAY THAT
SOMETIMES THE NATURE THE
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS.
IT HAPPENS THAT WAY SOMETIMES
IT'S NOT IDEAL BUT.
I THINK WE DO HAVE A PATH
FORWARD.
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED HERE
AROUND THE FUNDS AND OUT SORT OF
A UNIQUE STRUCTURE THERE.
SHOULD THIS BILL GOING
APPROPRIATIONS WILL CERTAINLY
REVIEW ALL OF THOSE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES SO THE GOAL HERE IS
CONSUMER PROTECTION PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC PROTECTING EMPLOYERS
OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
PROTECTING ATHLETIC TRAINERS
THEMSELVES THIS IS IT LICENSURE
THIS IS NOT WHAT I WANTED.
ULTIMATELY.
BUT I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP.
THAT PROTECTS THE PUBLIC AND
IT'S A BRIDGE I THINK ULTIMATELY
TO LICENSURE BUT THAT WILL BE A
A FULL CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER
DAY BUT AT THIS POINT I THINK WE
HAVE A GOOD PRODUCT.
I'M PROUD TO STAND.
BEHIND IT WITH THE ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS SOMEWHERE
MULLIN AND TO ECHOES THE.
COMMENTS FROM STAKEHOLDERS AS
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MAY
RECALL THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT
PRESENTATION FROM A MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT LAST WEEK AND OF COURSE
THIS WEEK WE ALSO HEARD. A
MEMBERS HAVINGAN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY WANT TO
THANK IN PARTICULAR OF VINCE CHI
ON THIS COMMITTEE STAFFER
SPENDING HOURS UPON HOURS. WHEN
MANY OF US WERE SLEEPING.
TO HELP ADDRESS A MANY
DIFFERENT CONCERNS AND THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY BEEN RAISED BY
OPPOSITION AT IN ADDITION IT IS
THE RECOGNITION THAT WE HAVE
MADE THAT YOU'VE RTF TOOK ELATED
ASSEMBLYMAN MULLIN. OF THAT YOU
TWO HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS AND TRYING TO GET IN
THIS IN ONE DIRECTION IT IS NOT.
THE SAME AS WAS PREVIOUSLY
PRESENTED AS YOU'VE INTRODUCED
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION A BUT
YET YOU'VE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF.
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION THE
TITLE PROTECTIONS OF THE
REGISTRATION AND CONTINUING TO
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD ON THIS
ISSUE A SIMILARLY YOU'VE HEARD
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO. ASK
FOR CONTINUED A CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND ENSURING
THAT WE CAN COME UP THE PRODUCT
AS BEST AS POSSIBLE AND BUT THEY
ARE GIVEN THE TIMELINE THAT WE
HAVE. ON THE LEGISLATIVE
TIMELINES AND THIS DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WHICH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE AYE LOW
AYE BRO.
PRO NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER BAKER NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN NOT VOTING TO.
CHIU AYE.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
I WILL NOT VOTING MULLIN.
A MOMENT I TING. TING AYE.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A MEMBERS WE'VE NOW COMPLETED
THE PRESENTATIONS OF ALL OF OUR
BILLS AND SO WILL GO THROUGH
FILE ORDER FOR ADDITIONAL.
AND ON SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH A
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
ONE.
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. AYE AYE LOW
AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
AND AND MY APOLOGIES MEMBERS WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND FOR
THAT.
THIS MOTION ANYTHING ABOUT
RAMBLIN SECOND BY SOME MEMBER
FALL.
OKAY.
.
SO FOR.
FILE ITEM NO. YES.
YOU JUST ASK FOR A MOTION A
SECOND ON THAT ITEM I DON'T
REMEMBER WHO VOTED FOR IT
EARLIER BUT I SLID TO.
I THINK IT'S THE ONLY A HIGH
LEVEL FOR IF THERE WAS NO DELAY
SINCE ACT ON THEM NO AUTHORS.
BECAUSE I DID JUST TO JUST TO
VERIFY THAT WHICH DO THEM NO OFF
THE. IT WAS NOT A MOTION A
SECOND IS THAT CORRECT.
TO THE WEST.
OKAY JUST ON THAT ONE.
OKAY THE HAPPY ISN'T. OKAY.
IT'S A WE HAVE A SOME OF THEM AS
AN AYE THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER CLARIFYING QUESTIONS ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
ONE.
OKAY WILL NOW MOVE ON THEN TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
IT'S BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND
THREE CIGARETTES.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY TO DO PASSED
AS AN EDITOR APPROPRIATIONS LOW
OUR LOW AYE ROUTE. BRO I
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
QUE THAT BILL HAS TO DEVOTE TO
LEAVE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM.
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS.
I'M SORRY THREE THIRTY ONE FORTY
THREE.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
TRANSLATOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE
DEPOSITOR PREPARATIONS LOW I'D
LOW AYE BRO. BRO I EMERALD
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
LIAM AYE CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
FOURTEEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
EL AYE AND TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOR WHICH IS THIRTY ONE FORTY
FOUR.
MOTION AND A SECOND CREE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY FAR DO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW AYE AYE
LOW I BROKE. BROUGH IRAN
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
AND WHEN.
I MEAN I FALL.
FONG I GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT IS THIRTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
CONSENT WHICH IS ITEMS EIGHT.
AND THE ITEM NUMBERS SIX AGAIN
ITEMS NUMBER SIX AND EIGHT FOR
CONSENT.
.
STATE MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY.
ITEMS RECOMMENDED FOR CONSENT
EIGHTEEN NO TO DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE AYE LOW
AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
FOURTEEN ZERO TWO THE ROLE OF AN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THIS IS A BE SET SEVENTEEN
NINETY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
PRESENTED WAS ALRIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY D. PASS AS
AN EDITOR PREPARATIONS LOW ARE
LOW I BRO. BRO AYE ARAMBULA.
RANDALL I BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE BLOOM.
WHEN I.
THIRTEEN ZERO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN.
WHICH IS A BE NINETEEN NINETY WE
NEED A MOTION.
MOTION AND A SECOND.
DAVID CHIU SIDE IF YOU.
THE SECTOR PICCOLO.
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW OUR
LOW EYEBROW. BROUGH AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER BAKER AYE
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
SO VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE UP
IN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
WHICH IS AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ALREADY.
WE'LL GO THROUGH THE BILL.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHEN.
CHEN NOW.
CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN.
TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS.
AND IS IT TIME FOR AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN.
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY EIGHT DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW. OUR
LOW AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
FIFTEEN ZERO WILL BE THE ROLL UP
IN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN.
WHICH IS TWENTY FIVE TWENTY.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND
HAS BEEN IN MOTION AND THAT AT.
AS I CAN BY SUMMER FONG
COMMITTEES AGRICULTURAL.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
AYE AYE LOW AYE BRO. BRO I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
PHONE AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THIRTEEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
REAL OPEN TRAPS IN MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX.
HAS BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
READY.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIXTY
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW TAR LOW AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
BAKER I.
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
FIFTEEN THERE WILL BE THE ROLE
UP IN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS AB
TWENTY SIX.
OH EIGHT.
THESE ARE GONNA MY SIGNATURE.
MOTION TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
CHEN.
CHEN NO.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
LEVIN THE FORCE THAT BILL IS OUT
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS LET'S SEE FILING OR.
FOURTEEN THIS IS AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO DEPOSIT
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOW CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE MULLIN.
MULIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
FIFTEEN TO ONE WILL BE THE ROLL
UP IN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NUMBERS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN WHICH IS AB TWENTY EIGHT
TEN THE AUTHOR A CERTAIN THE
REQUESTED A PRESENTATION ONLY SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN WHICH IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE. BY
SOME OR NAZARIAN.
AB WENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE D.
PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW AYE LOW
AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
SIXTEEN THERE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN WHICH
IS IT A. B. TWENTY NINE.
IT'S SEE I'M SORRY FILE ITEM
NUMBER. SEVENTEEN IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY EIGHT DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROAD
OPEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN WHICH
IS TWENTY NINE NINETY FOUR.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY FOUR TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. AYE LOW AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
SIXTEEN ZERO WILL EITHER OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
.
NOW MOVING ONTO A FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN WHICH IS AB.
THIRTY SIXTY SEVEN. BY SUMMER
JOB.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY MOOD BY SUMMER ARAMBULA AND
SECOND BY A AS A MEMBER TING.
AB THIRTY SIXTY SEVEN DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SLOW I'VE LOW AYE
BRO. BRO I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WELL NOW MOVE ON TO OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY WHICH IS A B.
THIRTY ONE TEN. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN.
AB THIRTY ONE TEND TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING. GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
CHEN.
CHEN I.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES IT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE AND IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE AND THIS IS THE
FINAL ONE WHICH IS A. B.. THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY SOMEONE
NUMBER RUBIO.
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY FAR DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
AYE AYE LOW AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
FIFTEEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROAD
OPEN FOR AFTER MEMBERS
.
MEMBERS WILL GO THE.
THROUGH THE ROLE AGAIN OUT ONE
FINAL TIME AND AT THE CONCLUSION
OF THIS THAT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.
THAT IS A FILE AND NEVER WON THE
FINAL VOTE IS SIXTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
FOLLOW THEM I ITEM NUMBER TWO
THREE ONE FOUR TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE
HOLDEN.
GIPSON.
FOURTEEN TO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE.
MOTIONS DAY PASSED UP OPERATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM IN OR FOR WHICH IS A
B. THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
FORTUNE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GIPSON HOLDEN.
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS
A BEAT NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
MOTIONS DE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG.
GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FIDO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH
IS AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
MOTIONS YOU PASTOR PREPARATIONS
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW.
HOLDEN.
ELEVEN FIVE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN WHICH IS AB
THIRTY TAUGHT AT AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY EIGHT.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.
IT SEEMS ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY. BY SUMMER
COOPER.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
FORTUNE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
FIFTEEN IS THERE THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX OH WAIT.
FINAL THE FINAL VOTE IS ELEVEN
FOR THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THE VOTE IS FIFTEEN TO ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN WHICH
IS AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE.
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY EIGHT.
MOST AS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY FOUR.
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN A. B.
THIRTY SIXTY SEVEN.
RUSSIA'S DE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN. EGGMAN
IPHONE.
GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY A. B.
THE THIRTY TEN.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN MOTIONS YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.
SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FINALLY FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR.
MOTIONS TO PASS ON THE MONITOR
PREPARATIONS HOLDEN.
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
AND THEN LET'S SEE I JUST GO
THROUGH CONSENT WHAT ONE LAST
TIME IF MEMBERS ARE STILL.
WISHING TO ADD ON.
ITEMS RECOMMENDED FOR HITS AT
EIGHTEEN I TO TO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR TO PASS AS A MANAGER
OF OPERATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN.
THAT IS FIFTEEN ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR IS UP.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN MOTIONS YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
I AM NOT VOTING.
AND THAT.
BILL IS NINE TWO ZERO
STEVE SEVEN MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
FONG.
I PLANT BUT.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THAT SAID AGAIN AB THIRTY SIXTY
SEVEN FIFTEEN ZERO.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY TAIL MOTIONS
YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
FIFTEEN ZERO.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE D.
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR.
MOTIONS D. PASTOR PREPARATIONS
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
FIFTEEN DESERVE THAT GOES OUT.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE.
IF TWO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEMS RECOMMENDED FOR CONSENT AB
EIGHTEEN A TO DO PASSED OF
REPARATIONS AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR TO PASS AS A MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE.
CONSENT DOLLARS EXTRA ZERO.
AB NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT MOTIONS
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE.
FORTUNE  THE BILL IS OUT.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT
MOTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE.
LIVE IN TO FIVE
THE BILL IS OUT.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX
MOTIONS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE.
TWO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
AB TWO NINE SIX EIGHT MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
SIX TWO ZERO THE BILL'S UP
.
AB THIRTY ONE TIME MOTIONS TO
PASS AS A MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN NOT VOTING.
NINE ZERO THE BILLS OUT.
AB THREE ONE EIGHT FOUR MOTIONS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN
.
REPEATING AB THREE OUR MOTION IS
TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
SEEMS ZERO ON THAT WAS ON AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR.
AB THREE ONE ONE ZERO.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AN INITIAL
PREPARATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
JONES IS ZERO THAT BILL IS STILL
OUT.
OKAY RICHARD